hello and welcome my name is michelle
covine and i'm with the simply learn
team
so here's our agenda we'll be talking
about business intelligence and why it's
important and some bi tools then we'll
talk about tableau and why we use
tableau for business intelligence and do
a quick overview of tableau installation
then we'll show you how you can get
started by connecting to data and we'll
do an overview of the tableau workspace
we'll go a little bit deeper into the
tableau workspace as we look at
worksheets and dashboards and we show
you how you can ask questions using
visualizations we'll look at hierarchy
and drill down calculated fields we'll
look at parameters and sets and finally
we'll show you how to build a donut
chart and a 2d pie chart so what is
business intelligence
companies use business intelligence
technologies to collect analyze and
present data in order to create
actionable information
today's businesses are always seeking
insights about their customers products
and services
so businesses are faced with many
questions such as how do i know my
customers are happy what would make my
customers stay and how can i increase
awareness of my products and services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers
there's also simple analytics built
right into tableau such as trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level tableau has
been a leader in the gartner magic
quadrant for the last six years and that
includes 2018. here we will take a look
at an overview of the products offered
by tableau so we have tableau desktop
which is where you do all of your
development this is where you connect to
and build visualizations and dashboards
today we'll be using tableau public
which is a free version of tableau
desktop but with some limitations such
as having no r integration and it can
only support up to a million rows of
data also any data published here is
made public so you can't use this for
private company information then there's
a new tool called tableau prep where you
can prepare your data by seeing it
visually before you connect and build
reports there's also tableau online
which is a cloud-hosted version of
tableau server a place where you can
publish your dashboards and it enables
you to share your dashboards in a secure
way tableau server has an option to be
on premises
so let's just do a quick comparison
between building a visualization in
excel and building one in tableau
okay so here we have an excel file full
of data that we will soon connect to and
use for some of our demonstration
purposes
and you can see that we have information
about orders if we wanted to find out
the quantity sold and the sum of sales
for each region we could do that by
creating a pivot table so we'll make it
i selected my cells we'll make it in a
new worksheet and here we have the
beginnings of a pivot chart and we can
grab region and pull it into our columns
and then we'll grab
sales and put it into values
um and then we also want to look at
quantity i put that into values and it's
automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be sum or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see
sales and quantity
one on top of the other and that's the
basics of a pivot chart now let's do a
similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab region and put
it onto columns
and we get a similar thing maybe a
little nicer formatted and then we can
come and put quantity
there
if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity
down in that box we also have this show
me dialog box which allows you to
see what visualizations you could build
using what's already on the screen or
the things that you have selected
so right now we could quickly switch it
to bar charts and now we can see
quantity and sales across our region
with bar charts or we could switch it to
stacked bars
and we can see a quantity across the
regions if you close that we can see our
legend over here and then our sales
across the region
so in tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization
so in summary we can see a side by side
of what we made using pivot tables in
excel and what we made in a similar
amount of time in tableau let's get
started with the tableau installation as
for requirements you need windows 7 or
later or you need your mac operating
system to be 10.11 or later here are
some of the browsers you can use to
install tableau we will be installing
tableau public today and to do that you
just google tableau public download and
click on that first link and then you
put in your email address and click
download the app so
let's just
look up tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now
it takes you to the tableau public page
where you can click sign in and create
an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file
that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open tableau public so let's go
take a look at the tableau public
opening page
so this is what tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to
this is more limited in tableau public
than it is in tableau desktop so if you
invest in tableau desktop you have
many many things you can connect to you
can also connect to data by clicking
this drop down connect data piece that's
especially useful when you've already
started your visualization
then we have the central portion called
open this is where anything that you
have opened up previously will show up
you can also click open from tableau
public and when you have
my connections timed out so i need to
log in
but when you log in
it says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos
visualization of the day which is where
people who have made tableau public
visualizations get
recognized for their skill and you get
some pretty cool ideas when you look
there
so let's get started by connecting to a
data source we'll click microsoft excel
and we'll choose our excel file and open
it up and this is our data source pane
this shows you the sheets on the excel
file and allows you to drag them in so
that you can see the data show up this
gives you a preview of what your data
will look like
you can see the tableau is starting to
classify our fields so anything that has
abc on it
shows that that's a column that has
strings in it we also have a globe which
is where tableau has recognized these
values to be geographical
so we have
state and it's recognized that it
contains states it bases it on
the keywords that it stores to identify
if it's geographical and so it takes a
look and you've named it city and it
knows that city is geographical we also
have the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row id that shows up with the
hashtag and i recognize that it's a
number so now that we have our data
source pulled in we can come here and
hit sheet which is where you start to
build your visualization let's take a
look at all the different pieces of this
before we go any further we have the
data that we're connected to up here is
our orders sheet from the sample super
store excel sheet we have dimensions on
top and measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the row
shelf where you can drag things in to
make changes happen in the visualization
center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here
a neat thing about show me is that when
you hover
it'll tell you what types of fields you
need to build it so for a symbol map try
one geographical field
zero or more dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map
and when you're done with show me you
just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet one and sheet two a sheet
is basically just one visualization at a
time
let's get rid of the extra sheet we have
a dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called the story
which allows you to show
a sequence of visualizations so that you
can tell a story
perfect okay so we saw that tableau is
categorizing
our different fields
and it is also giving it a role
so we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's sum by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see its four distinct
values as a dimension
and then we'll double click on quantity
and we can see the
numbers here the measures and you can
see here that it is the sum of quantity
and now we can also double click on
sales and we can see quantity and sales
to discuss a little bit more about
dimensions and measures you can see that
in general measures are numbers and
dimensions are not but sometimes like
row id it is a number now why would we
have a number up here instead of in the
measures so you can tell the difference
between number whether it should be in
measures or it should be in dimensions
based on whether you'll need to do any
calculations on it or if you would want
to be able to aggregate it at some time
so for
sales
if you have
several orders in a day you might want
to know what the sum of those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they're on rows 2 3 4 and 5 you
might not want to know the sum of the
rows so tableau is smart enough that
when it sees id it knows that it belongs
up in the dimensions now you can switch
so if row id was actually something you
would want to aggregate for some reason
you can drag it down to the measures and
add it down there
but in our case row id isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green a little bit
different than what you might expect and
then we'll do sales so now we can see
over the different quantities what our
sales was it has been for this last this
period of time that we're looking at i
believe it's four years so for when
people bought three items the total
sales was
that number and you can see that this is
an axis so it's from one to fifteen now
if we change it from continuous to
discrete you can see that 1 is a label 2
is a label and it's not an axis ranging
from 1 to it doesn't even have 15
because there are no values under 15.
these are just individual labels so we
go back it's green again and you can see
that it's an axis so we have two greens
on here so we have two axes and change
it back to discrete and now we have one
axes and one set of individual labels so
let's go back to our sheet three we have
all of these different
sales by the different quantity numbers
and up here we have our sorting when you
hover it tells you what kind of sorting
is going to happen so we could sort
quantity descending by sales so we can
see that when they buy three things we
have the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right clicking sort so we
could just sort
by
descending or ascending or by sales or
alphabetic
which is
not what we want
you can choose the field or you can
manually change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how tableau works let's go into a
little more detail
tableau is very much built on the
premise of drag and drop
so
let's build a simple visualization
and talk about
what each of these shelves and marks
cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region
so we know we want
sales
on let's do sales on
rows now for rows and for metrics since
this is continuous like we talked about
before it's making an axes
for our sales
we also can drag
region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
dimensions if you
pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying i want one
blank per column i want one region per
column so if you wanted to do it by
instead of region
if you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control z
tableau has the benefit of having
unlimited undo's so let's say we wanted
to
bring on city let's say we want one
column per
city and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
city back off i want one column per
region
and for
sales
i want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great
now let's say we want to adjust the
color of these bars you can click on
color and you can select any of them so
let's pick this nice blue
or we can pick an orange
and that's how you can determine
the color
but if you want
something else to determine the color
you can take
region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale
so
if i want them to be
a different color based on sales and i
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous
from light to dark but for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great um
let's say we want to sort this
biggest to smallest
and we can look at size here so if we
want to adjust the size manually we can
click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on
sales we will drag sales onto size and
we can see that it gets bigger with
bigger sales we do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures
for label let's say we want the sales on
to label now we can see
the exact sales
number
for each
region
what if we wanted the name of the region
there as well we can drag region onto
labels and we can see sales for the west
region
you can adjust which one goes on top
see how we have two t's here those are
both labels great uh two tip
when we click on tool tip it'll show us
what's going to happen
when we hover so as i hover here on east
it says region east sales and that shows
the sales amount
now we talked about
i'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average of sales so
we will right click on our sum of sales
here in the rows hover over measure
which right now is sum and change it to
average and we have a different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the south
region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum i mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average now we can see
our average on the label
uh the label has some interesting
options
like you can format this
and we could say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue
and that happens right there
you can also choose to only show
the minimum and the maximum
this becomes handy on
a line chart where you don't want all
marks labeled because it gets very messy
but you want the tallest and the
shortest part to be labeled and maybe
you just want the tallest so we'll click
label minimum value and remove that
checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so
we could allow people
to look at this
but from only
certain regions so what we can do is we
can come over to region and right click
on it and click show filter and it will
add it to that filters card and now we
can remove central from the mix and just
look at those ones you see if we remove
south the new highest east now has the
label but if we put it back in south
will have the label again if we don't
want to have these filters
we can pull it off there or if we wanted
to filter out
by country oh we just have united states
so let's not filter by country um but we
could pull in
category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all
they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the south still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology
you can see the difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that i can mention
here
is that you can change the type of mark
manually so you saw when we pulled on
region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it too based on region
if we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there
you can change it to be a lot of
different type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay
now
let's
look at
building a scatter plot so scatter plot
is when you have a bunch of shapes and
points on a visualization with two axes
that are both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the
y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount
and if we wanted to see this per order
we'll take order id and put it on to
detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order id and putting onto
detail
gives us all of these little points so
for each order what was our sales and
what was our discount so we have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly
let's actually do
product id instead so i'll put it right
over top of order id and it will replace
it
now we see all of our products
anything that has high sales is up here
anything that has high discount is over
here you can see that it sort of has a
trend
where
things with high sales do not have high
discounts which makes sense if we wanted
to
know what
category these products i'll show up in
we could take category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show
just the dimension that you want to see
but it leaves the other ones in place so
for example if we click on furniture
first we have to turn on the highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization
and how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern
for them when we click on technology
we can see their pattern which is a
little bit different so we have them by
shape with category let's drag category
onto color as well if you remember
category will determine the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items
they're all over here and most of the
things that are getting
high discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here
now we could take that product id and
find out what that product actually is
out of our oh look we have product name
let's replace product id with product
name
and we see that that is a canon image
class advanced copier
so this copier is our big sales person
and
office supplies binders do not give us
very many sales and we're highly
discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so
let's say
we wanted to know by subcategory what
our profit is like
we could grab
subcategory and pull it onto columns and
we would say we want one column per
subcategory
and then let's grab profit
and pull it onto rows
and you can quickly see
which categories
are profitable and which ones are not so
we can also take profit and put it onto
color
so that you can see that even more
clearly
right now it is going from orange to
blue which is tableau's default if we
wanted to change
from what color to what color it was
going we have a lot of options in here
when you go to edit colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the prophet
that's negative is bad so we can hit
apply and now we can see red to blue we
have our categories here our
subcategories here but let's separate it
out by category so what i'm going to do
i'm going to take subcategory off
i'm going to put on category and that's
my category and then i'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory so
furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking out by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have
our profit by category by sub category
and we can
click
sort subcategory descending by profit
and now what it does is within the
highest group within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so
what we have here
is a quick view by category by
subcategory how we're doing on profit we
can see that
tables is our biggest drain on profit
and so if we wanted to improve the
profitability of furniture
maybe we would
not sell tables anymore it's just not
working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it
is you can see that there's some of
these words are getting cut off so
we can right click on this axis and
click
rotate label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet so if we rename the
sheet to
profit by
sub category
then it names the title up here so this
is making it look a little bit better
and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit and click format and you can see
that we can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and
we can do it currency by the thousands
now we can get rid of these decimal
places
and now you can see it's just a little
bit nicer
a little bit more clear maybe we don't
have to have the label here that says
category subcategory so we can hide
field labels for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in tableau
is one of those things where there are
just a lot of different ways you could
change things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are
building these visualizations if you
want to
have access to this data set so that you
can build along with me just make a
comment in the comments below and the
simply learn team will send you this
data set now we're going to take a look
at creating a hierarchy in tableau
so we'll make a new tab
and we're going to make a sheet
called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at sales as a
number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this i'm going to click add
all members and now we can see all of
our products and their sales
overall time so if we sort this we can
see our highest sale selling item which
we discovered earlier as the advanced
copier and we scroll down to the bottom
our lowest selling items
so we have our products and we can group
that by sub category
and you can see i need to put it in the
front again
and by category
all right i'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so
a product rolls up into a subcategory
which rolls up into a category you can
create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory
let's do the same thing by grabbing
the product name and putting it
underneath subcategory so now it knows
categories the parent then there's
subcategory and then there's product
name this allows you to instead of
pulling this off or putting it back on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales
by category by subcategory by product
name this is really useful when you're
creating a details section for your
users
and so when somebody wants to know
let's say you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
show filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like i see technology has the
highest sales and i just want to see
technology so i'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so i
just have technology well i want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it
phones phones does so i just actually
want to look at phones so i'm going to
remove accessories copiers and machines
and what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now i can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first i'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by
showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly
so what we can do is take
sales and drag it onto color let's
change our marks to a square and now
it's going to color each of these it
colors every one of these cells based on
its darkness for sales this is a little
bit heavy of a color you can click color
here and change the opacity to give it a
little bit
of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the west seems to have the highest
sales and that technology in the east is
the very highest so now when we
drill into sub-category it keeps that
coloring and we can see more in depth
and quicker that phones has the highest
across most of them it's not quite the
highest in the west because chairs is
the highest in the west there is one
place in tableau where hierarchies are
built in
and that's in dates so dates in tableau
can be very complex because they allow
very complex visualizations so we will
not go into depth about dates at this
time but let's take a look at how they
work for hierarchies so we have order
date that we can pull onto columns here
and you can see that it's blue meaning
that it's discrete so each one of these
is a header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag
profit
onto rows
so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when i click this
plus on
columns it'll split it out into quarters
so this is a header and these are all
sub headers underneath that header
because it is distinct
um and discrete right now instead of
continuous so it's split out year year
year year and quarters quarters quarters
quarters this allows you to quickly
compare quarter one across all of the
years and quarter two across all the
years and quarter four across all the
years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out a color and now
we have one line for each category and
we can see that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here
quarter and quarter now the top ones are
all discrete and when i change it to a
bottom one
year same thing same here it changes it
to be green and now it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when i
press the plus and then changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going and drill down to
month
you can go pretty far now when we add
category as color
we get our three lines for the three
categories and we also have highlighting
turned on here still so when we click on
technology we can highlight technology
with the others in the background so we
don't lose the context of the other
categories
let's take that back off
next let us talk about calculated fields
so we'll make a new sheet and we're
going to create our first calculated
field we can create a calculated field
by clicking this arrow which gives us
some options and clicking create
calculated field or we can come and
click in the white space below
dimensions or below measures and we
right click and click create calculated
field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or
values you can use or you can come and
drag it in so if we want profit and we
want sales if we do profit divided by
sales that is a profit ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate
and that will duplicate our field but i
just want to start over again so i'll
click create calculated field
and i would call it profit
ratio
aggregated
and in this one we're gonna do sum click
of profit
click divided by
sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio on
aggregated how will those behave
differently in tableau let's look at
this by looking at a single
order
so first let's bring on all the orders
and all the products
under that order and let's look at this
order
so
i want to filter this whole dashboard to
only this order so i can right click on
it and click keep only that creates a
filter up here
that only has that box checked
and if i want to get rid of this later
i can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but i want
it so
keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated i double clicked on it
and i added it here
and profit ratio unaggregated again
double clicking and now they're side by
side let's give us a little bit more
room
so when i dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side and the entire titles okay so i
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and i brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now
so when we're looking at it without any
aggregation these two calculations are
the same profit ratio aggregated let's
look at that again we'll click edit and
that's the one where we sum profit and
some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that i use when i'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what i expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at
point five or fifty percent and that's
because profit is eight and sales is
sixteen for adam's telephone messaging
now
let's take off product name when we take
off product name we can see that they
start to vary we've got profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio unaggregated
so here we have profit and sales the
profit ratio should be profit divided by
sales so let's open up a calculator
and make it a little smaller
so if we take profit at
219.1 and divide it by sales at 508.6
we get 0.4 not 1.8 so where does this
1.8 come from
well let's put product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however
does the calculation profit divided by
sales and then
sums it afterwards you can see it right
here it's the sum of profit ratio on
aggregated so it makes this calculation
and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5 and that's where we get our 1.8
which is what we see
when we pull off product name 1.8 so for
most calculations you want to do profit
ratio aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region
now let's say we also wanted to see
each region
by sales per customer so let's create
some calculated fields that will help us
do that let's create our first
calculated field
that's going to get us a count of
customers
let's call it total
number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer id let's do
count distinct
of customer id and that gives us the
total number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it
sales per
customer
we're going to do our sum
of sales which we can drag in
and divide that by
total number of customers now you see
that calculated field we just made pops
up inside of our calculation
dialog box and we hit apply
and it shows up so we hit ok and let's
replace
total number of customers
with
sales per customer and now we can see
our sales per customer ratio and which
ones have the highest or for this next
part i'm going to make a couple of
visualizations in a row that all applied
to the same information using a couple
of different tactics so
first let's use show me so i want to
look at
region
and sales for this visualization so i'm
going to control click
region
after i click sales so one more time i'm
going to
click on sales and i'm going to control
click region
and i'm going to click show me and it's
going to give me all of the different
visualizations i could make with region
and sales let's pick
tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales
by region
and we have the size and the color of
the box is both sales so let's say we
wanted the size to be sales but the
color to be profit so let's grab profit
and drag that on to sales so now we can
see our most profitable to our least
profitable let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to advanced and
make the center number
zero
this means that it will never be red
unless it's less than zero so let's hit
apply so it's all blue and if anything
ever goes negative then it will be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales
profit by region
perfect
now we're going to start using our
geographical
fields so we have state city country and
postal code let's double click on state
and see what happens
awesome so it is
generated these two fields tableau has
generated longitude and latitude for us
and it's been able to recognize the
states in the united states and where
they're located and given it a longitude
and latitude
so next we will look at sales
by state by double clicking on sales and
what it's done was change the size of
the dot based on sales now i think i'm
going to move sales from size to color
and it has automatically changed it to a
filled map instead of dots on a map
perfect so now we can see the states
with the
biggest amount of sales
let's put it back onto size and we have
our circles again
let's put sales on the size not stay
down to size and we have our circles
again but let's make them a little bit
bigger
these two marks on the tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the builder okay
so we have size for
sales again and for profit onto color
again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable
or less than zero in this case is orange
let's do what we did with color before
change it to
red blue diverging and set our center
point to zero okay so now we know that
if anything is red it was negative in
profit perfect let's name this sheet
sales
profit
by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so
this is when we drag something to the
columns shelf just remember we want one
column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what i want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and technology
now let's
take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart
by clicking on its appropriate marks
card so if we want to change them both
we can click on all
and change them both to maybe circles
and you can see how they go up and down
but if we want to just change
one of them let's put those back to
automatic we'll go to profit and change
that one to
the circles so now we can see
those profit numbers and if we want them
to be overlaid on the same area
we would right click on profit the
second measure on the rows and click
dual axis so now let's put them onto the
same axis you can see that their axes
are not lined up let's go to sales and
change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space
one of them is a bar chart and one of
them is a bubble chart and we can see
our sales versus our profit at least
they're not the same amount of dollars
obviously but we can see a higher
sales and a higher profit we also have
medium sales and a medium profit we have
a medium sales but a really low profit
and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet
as
sales
profit
by category
and
finally we're going to make our details
sheet so we're going to go down to
subcategory level and bring it onto rows
and remember subcategory can expand out
to the actual products let's bring that
back in and we're going to bring sales
onto columns which makes us a sales bar
chart and profit onto columns which
makes us a profit bar chart now let's
color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color
now sales is colored by sales we'll do
the same thing here we did before
we'll go red blue diverging
[Music]
and make the center zero we actually
don't have to do that for sales because
sales will never be
negative but it's pretty important for
profit so we'll go to the profit marks
card and take profit onto color
and do the same thing there we have
red blue diverging
advanced center is zero great
so now if it's negative it will be there
so let's sort this
by profit and so both of them have
sorted with profit in mind and we can
easily see our subcategories that have a
negative profit
rename this
and we'll call it our details sheet
so now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do
with similar information
i think i want these bigger on the
states so we'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have
information over here that shows you
what sheets you can bring on these get a
little bit more complex so they'll be
covered in more in-depth type of videos
and then we have our size so
we could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size
and we're going to make it
1400 by a thousand and this is our
dashboard size so let's bring on
sales profit by region sales and profit
by state now a map needs a little bit
more horizontal space
than region does let's bring sales and
profit by category underneath the region
and the detail underneath the state give
our map more space again
perfect
now tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if i click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
i just want to look at the south and i
click on south it zooms into all my
south states now my categories have
updated to be just the south ones and my
details have updated as well so we could
see that central
has pretty big sales you know bigger
than the south but the profit is lower
than the south so we can click on
central and focus on central
let's use
that uses filter
on all three of these
dashboards that lead us up to the detail
so building a quick dashboard like this
let's make this taller would allow you
to do some sort of analysis such as
let's take a look at central because
they have relatively high profits but
low sales so we click on central and
then we see oh man texas is having a
really hard time so let's click on texas
and now we're seeing in texas that we
have
negative profit in these categories so
we can control click on furniture and
office supplies and we can see all of
our products that are really just
killing us in texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you
back out of that subcategory section you
can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet and
let's make a quick visualization that
we'll apply our parameters and our sets
too
so let's take a look at all of our
customers
by their sales and let's sort
customer name descending by sales great
so now we're going to make a parameter
that will allow the user of the
dashboard to choose how many customers
they want to see how many of our top
customers that they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make it an integer
and we're going to give them the option
to choose the number of customers within
a range our low is going to be 5 so
we'll let them see 5
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of 5. let's start the current
value right in the middle with 10.
okay so now if you want to see how this
parameter looks you can come down to
parameters before we only had dimensions
and measures on the left side of our
tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
that parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allow them to go down to five
and
up to 20 with steps of five
great now we're going to create a set a
set is a custom field that defines a
subset of data based on some conditions
so the set we're going to build is going
to be based on customer name so when you
right click on customer name you can
come down and click create hover on
create and create a set with so far when
we created a parameter and a calculated
field you clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and
customers
buy sales so we're going to allow them
to select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
defined by the parameter
by sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10 we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here
for it to be defined by and it's sales
and we want it to be by sum of sales
if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers by average profit
but we want sales and some
okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it on to rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10
and let's grab the set and drag it onto
our filters so now we have filtered the
data down to our top 10. if this were
applied to a dashboard this would allow
the end user to see the top 10 quickly
and then maybe expand it out to the top
20 if they're interested in that
information now let's move on to
creating a donut chart so a donut chart
is basically a pie chart with a white
center so let's start by building a pie
chart which in tableau is pretty easy
especially if you use show me so let's
create a pie chart
for each
category by sales so you're going to
click category and then we're going to
control click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click
pie and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pi
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one pi for each
region we can take region and drag that
onto columns so we have one column for
each region and then one pie for each of
them you can see that the pie varies in
size based on sales as well as the angle
is for sales so east has more sales in
general than south and this helps you to
see that technology
has smaller sales in the south than it
does in the east so i recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of size and
now we have all of our pie charts the
same size now we're going to make what's
called a dual axis chart and to make a
dual axis chart we have to have two axes
so let's grab
number of records and we'll grab it and
drag it to rows and we will change it
from sum to minimum and that's because
every record will have a minimum number
of rows of one and then they all end up
on the same axis great and now we're
going to make a second number of records
by minimum and we can do that by doing
those steps again by dragging number of
records up here and changing it to
minimum again
or a quick trick that i can show you is
if you want to
duplicate anything you have on the chart
here you can just hit control and then
click and drag it and it will duplicate
it so if you wanted your number of
records to also be down here onto your
details or on your labels you can
control click it and then leave it there
great so now we have our two axes and we
have our two marks cards that each
affect their own
set of visualizations so let's go to
this top one affects these so let's show
that by changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to
circle so now each of these are a circle
let's take category off of color and we
can take some of sales off of detail and
let's change the color to white
and now we're going to put this white
circle on top of our pie chart by
clicking here on our second measure
and clicking dual axis and now it's got
them lined up one on top of the other
and we have our donut chart so if we
want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our inner circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one doughnut chart for
each region and if we wanted to take
this header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here
you can come and edit that by clicking
on label and changing its alignment so
let's put it in the middle
perfect so now we can see
our header here so we don't need it down
here anymore you can right click and
click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies
so to get how the number of sales here
for each of them let's go to
remember our pie marks card and let's
take
our sales and add it to label so now
each of our slices of pie can tell you
how much sales they have if you take the
sales here that's on label right click
and click format we can change that to
currency
and let's get rid of our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with central so we
go back to affecting our circle grab
sales drag it to label so now we have
four donut charts formatted to allow us
to quickly see the sales numbers for
each segment and also for the donut as a
whole you can also change the colors
that tableau selects for each slice by
coming to the marks card that has color
for the pie so category color and
clicking edit colors and you could
change it to
any of these automatic ones
where if you double click on one it
gives you all of the options for colors
that you could possibly want there's
also several different palettes you
could choose from so let's say we like
this one and you can just click assign
palette and it will grab those off of
there those look very similar to what we
have already so i'm going to pick a
different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes and you fit your business a
little bit more specifically perfect
let's say
we make our
pies bigger
crease that size
and we'll also increase the center size
oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show
two pie charts at the same time or a pie
chart that's kind of split up by
different categories this has been
available in some other tools and
tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our
generic category
by sales so with control click sales we
come over to show me and click pie and
it makes our pie for us it remembers the
colors that you have determined in other
pages so that's a nice feature again
let's make it entire view so we can see
our pi nice and big and now we're going
to
create our dual axis again so we grab
number of records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes and let's come to
our top one
and make it bigger that affected both of
them because we still have sales on size
for both of them so sales is affecting
the size of the pie chart as well as the
size of the angles so let's take sales
off of size
for both of them
and make the second pie chart a little
smaller perfect now let's also affect
our second pie chart by having the color
defined by region instead of defined by
sales let's talk about how i'm replacing
it with region so you could change the
color by dragging region onto color and
that replaces it or let's go back and we
can drag region right on top of the
thing we're trying to replace and it
will replace it there
great so now we have the smaller circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the category is on the top one with
the angle defined by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to i'm just going to keep following
this right down
click apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner pie
separate from the outer pie maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger
like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
that change that zero line to none
perfect get rid of some of the clutter
on this visualization i still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have min number of records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come tool tip right as
you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase
mid number of records i erased too much
you need to leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
min number of records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen these visualizations are a little
bit more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so i recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below and
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have
at this point in the presentation we're
going to put together some dashboards so
first let's build our worksheets for
this dashboard we're going to build a
worksheet
called
sales by
year which adds the name up here and
we're going to
take our order date and drag it onto
columns and now we want this to be a
continuous axis so we're going to change
it to our continuous year and now we
have an axis and we're going to look at
sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto
labels and if we want to have different
color lines for each region for example
we can drag region onto color
and that splits our lines up
into the different regions and gives us
a legend over here perfect now we're
going to duplicate this sheet by right
clicking down here and clicking
duplicate now we have sales by year two
let's rename it to
profit
by year
and then let's drag profit
right over top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
of these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
some of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our axis
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like
right click here go format and we'll
change our numbers to
currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars
one thing you can do in tableau is
let's undo that
since
sales is going to be dollars pretty much
everywhere we use it we can define our
default property for these numbers so
when we right click on the measure here
you can go to default properties and you
have the options to change the defaults
for any of these things and we're going
to change our number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit ok and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet
let's do the same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this
our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine i think it fits nicely on the
laptops that i use and that is used by
most of our customers now let's drag
sales by year now watch what happens
when i drag it on here it brings sales
by year but it also brings the legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on central and you
see it highlights central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit ok and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here
and we're going to do
a similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here
so now we have
a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
and so when we go to overall
we can come to our
drop down here more options
hover over filters
and you can see category now here's an
interesting thing that we'll see even
though we have a category filter on both
charts when i take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be
that's because we have two different
filters for category one on the sales
worksheet and one on the profit by year
worksheet i'll show that
by clicking here going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so
let's back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year now we're going to take off
category
let's go to sales by year and we're
going to say we want this same filter to
affect both worksheets so we're going to
right click here hover over apply to
worksheets and click selected worksheets
now we select sales by year is selected
and we select profit by year okay so
when we go to
the profit by year
sheet you can see that it now has
category on there let's go to overall
let's come here
filters category and now we have a
filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now
you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do
a couple more filters so we can do by
category
let them filter out regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them
change their
time selection so this one's a little
bit different since we've already
determined that we wanted year and we
wanted it to be continuous filters for
continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for
these discrete fields
and that's because continuous fields are
a range instead of just a list so we
don't list out a continuous field we
make a range for it so we've already
defined that we want it to be continuous
year and if i come over here and click
on right click order date and click show
filter it's doing discrete year by
default
so
remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick
what you want it to look at
um let's come up here to year that's
already marked as continuous and click
show filter and now it is year but it's
based on a range and we have this slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization
let me show you a trick to make this
apply to both not a trick but just if
you have not applied it to both
worksheets but you already added it to
the visualization see it's here but it's
only affecting one worksheet you can
change the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to
the worksheet where the filter
exists and it will only give you the
options of the worksheets that are on
the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by
each of the regions we can do that as
well so let's go back to our sales sheet
as a quick tip you can go to the sheet
by clicking this go to sheet button here
or here
in the event that you want to go to a
sheet but you don't want to scroll back
and forth to find where it is so go to
sheet now we're going to do a dual
access chart again like we showed
earlier and i'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by if i change the
opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the rows section and click dual axis
so let's put it right on top i can see
this versus this now if we wanted to on
hover show that this is overall sales we
can click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put
oh we don't want it to be orange let's
make it black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it um a
little bit more of a color that'll stand
out just a little darker than the others
perhaps
so when we go back to our work or our
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for profit by year
go to sheet and
control
drag
release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region make it
darker
change our tool tip
not orange
overall
profit
okay
and right click
dual axis
there we go now i forgot to do one thing
on the last dashboard when you make a
dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
sync up these axes and so this axis over
here is for the overall line and this
axis over here is for the region line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should
edit our axes
and instead of calling it just profit
over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit
by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one
or you can come here and click
synchronize axes so it's very clear that
this is much bigger than these
and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him
okay synchronize the axis
then we don't need both of these headers
so we can come here and click show
header and we just have the one let's do
the same thing on sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind
when we do
filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
if we filter to 2
then it's only the sum of those two
so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered
why does this happen
why doesn't this line always show the
total no matter what you select here
well that's because this filter applies
to the whole dashboard so it filters
this line to those regions just as much
as it filters these lines
so i'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so
let's do it using show me we'll click on
region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click pie let's close it
again great so now we have the sales by
region pie we'll make it the entire view
and when you hover you can see that it's
showing us sales in dollar amounts now
it would be
more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole
at 100
so let's come here to our slice size
we'll right click on it and we're going
to use what's called a quick table
calculation
and change it to percent of total so now
when you hover you can see that the west
is 31
of the pie
great
let's also label each of these slices so
i'm going to control click and drag
region onto label
and add region to the labels i'm going
to undo that and show you what would
happen if i just dragged region onto
labels without copying it without
holding control it will move it and get
rid of our colors and we don't want that
so we're going to control and drag
another way to do this let's go back is
by taking region and dragging it onto
label just straight from over here but
in this case for the sum of sales where
we've applied the quick table
calculation we want that quick table
calculation to also show up in our label
so i'm going to control and drag
and it brings that quick table
calculation along with it if i were to
undo just drag sales
on it's going to go back to that dollar
amount and i'm going to have to add
another quick table calculation so
instead ctrl and drag
that's probably one of my very favorite
tableau tricks great now let's add a
filter for region so i'm going to right
click here and click show filter and we
will make sure that this gets added to
all of our sheets once we've made them
all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet
sales by state
let's do a map great so um one way to
get your map started is to double click
on any of these dimensions that have a
globe next to them so with since we want
to go with state we can double click on
state and it starts mapping out state so
what it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here and another way to
get going so let's go back is to click
on the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map
sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
gonna do a field map
click on that so now we have our field
map based on state
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label
and you can see we have the dollar sign
and the money formatting that we made
earlier and let's control and drag state
onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here
on the ellipses
and edit it there so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there i think i lost my
center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think
great okay so now you can see that it
puts the state on top you can also see
in some of these places where they're
super close together that you can't see
all of the state's labels and that's
because this option here in labels is
unchecked allow labels to overlap other
marks so tableau senses when the marks
are too close together and it's going to
become too hard to read and will hide
anything that overlaps with each other
if we click this option now you see
everything but it gets a little crowded
over here
so let's unselect that and you'll be
able to see what the sales are upon
hover
great now we have our sales by state
for filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your dimensions are
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters um so now we
could uh the lowest amount for a state
is 920
for sales for this time period and we
could filter out ones that have sales
lower than that but
i think this isn't what i want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
state show filter great so now we could
filter out
a state we could just show
arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization new sheet
rename it to be called sales by
sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategory we could
either drag on subcategory here or
because of our hierarchy press plus now
we have subcategory and category and
let's bring on sales it's defaulting to
this bar chart which is perfect that's
what i want and now we could color it by
subcategory and this is a discrete
coloring we could also color it by
sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to add to
the distinction between the different
categories so that's very clear
where they start and stop let's do
by sub category excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for subcategory so let's
bring on
category as our filter so we'll right
click here click show filter there's
category and let's do a filter for
our date so we're going to come here to
order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all
and hit ok
right click here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can
check and uncheck boxes to choose what
years we want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard
our sales dashboard and
change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and
let's start with pulling on our sales by
region so last time we pulled on a chart
we saw that it added the legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the legend
and the filter so last time we created
the filters after we built the dashboard
but this time you can see that the
filter um gets brought in when we
brought in the dashboard let's do our
sales by state side by side here and
let's do sales by subcategory underneath
so i dragged it you can see how i pull
it towards the bottom of the dashboard
and it kind of fills in the space where
it's going to be
and then brings it in so now it's
brought in all our filters and all of
our legends it defaults to putting the
filters and legends over here we're
going to click select a layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
going to make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and
a lot of resizing to get things the way
you want them to be give our map more
room and we have a mixture over here of
legends and
filters let's move our legends out of
there so we can grab this legend and
come and put it on this side
and this legend come and put it over
here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this legend goes up here with this one
i'm going to actually click here and
change it from
a tiled so right here it says tiled
object to a floating object that lets it
sit on top of a visualization i'm going
to put it on top of this visualization
right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one
circle there's no size comparison so
it's not like we have several circles
and we have to look and see which one's
the biggest so that we can tell the the
amount of sales so we don't need this
legend and we can just remove it from
the dashboard let's clean up some of
these we have several different versions
of what your filters could look like so
my personal favorite is multiple values
drop down it gives you some of the most
flexibility
but if you wanted them to only be able
to select a single value you could turn
it into a radio button list so that it's
a selected all or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so
let's do
multiple value drop-downs um for big
ones like state there is the option
of searching so i know i want utah and i
search and there's utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region
by doing this oh this is a great
reminder you saw that this did not
change all the visualizations we have
yet to apply these filters to all the
worksheets so let's do that right now
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
and we will click all on dashboard
hit ok
we'll do this again
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe um a total number up here at
the top that you just wanted to stay the
same all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters okay great so
we can change what region we're looking
at by selecting central here and then
we're just looking at central throughout
all the visualizations i love looking at
it on a map and seeing just one at a
time it just really makes the region
name just stand out to you but if we
wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when i filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at texas
we click this this updates to just
central this updates to just texas down
here
and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say
let me scroll down a bit storage now
everything updates to the storage it's
interesting i wouldn't have known very
quickly that there are some states that
didn't have any storage sales but now
when we click on storage we can tell i
showed you before that you can control
click and look at binders and storage
and it puts those two together also in
tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
i don't know what's up with wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and
let's get started on our next one our
next dashboard is going to be the profit
version of this dashboard so some of
these visualizations we can use again so
let's go to sales by region right click
and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
i mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere
that sales is used you have to replace
it with profit i'm also going to drag
this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall then the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the sides of the circle
shouldn't make a difference since we
only have one circle and onto the text
now when i dragged it on it didn't do
the percent of total anymore so let's
change that
to the quick table calculation of
percent of total for their and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in a region filter
and this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now
so you might want perhaps there would be
a situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what i want great so
another one we can use the basics for is
sales by subcategory so let's duplicate
that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier tableau will
not allow you to make a worksheet that
has the same name as another worksheet
you can
call it number one or since it does put
the title up here you can put an extra
space at the end or it does detect that
space it counts it as a different title
even though it's the same title just
with a space that does cause some issues
so like when we're looking here and
we're saying oh profit by subcategory i
want that oh this is when we made it but
you don't want this one you want this
one and it gets a little confusing the
nice thing is when you're dragging
things onto your dashboard when you
hover you should get a little picture
here of what dashboard what
visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all these called sheet 5 sheet 7
you won't know exactly what that is
right away so that little preview is
very helpful great profit by sub
category we'll do the same thing by
removing out all our filters so i just
click on it and hit delete
you can also control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on
category as a filter okay
show filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you can just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so i'll rename this and call it
profit
over time
by category
so we're going to
bring on our order date into columns and
it goes to our discrete value let's
change it to our continuous value so we
get the axis let's grab our profit onto
rows and it makes us a line chart we're
going to change that to an area chart an
area chart is nice because when you
split it up by category by dragging
category onto color you can now see
what category is responsible for how
much profit like you do with a line
chart however its area is what defines
that so you can see that area over time
and do comparisons and also it stacks
them on top of each other so that you
can tell that for 2013 our profit was
around fifty thousand dollars really
quickly otherwise we have to add that
line this line here and it makes these
lines smaller
and lower um more difficult to see so
back to our profit over time by category
so that's some of the benefits of having
an area chart and if we wanted to go a
little more detailed than year you can
hit this plus and now we have over
quarter we have some negative profits
that's interesting but let's go back to
every the year great and for this one
we're going to make one more pie chart
so we could start from scratch or we
could duplicate our profit by region pie
chart which i'm going to do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on tool
tips will affect your level of detail in
the visualization here when it's on
tooltips sometimes it won't change the
level of detail but it could have an
effect on like so if we brought oh let's
do this right now so right now the level
of detail of this chart does not go to
the category by
region like it did before you can bring
it onto detail here and it won't affect
color and it won't affect labels but it
will change the detail and you see how
it splits it out again this is what it
would look like if it's by region by
category and you have much more slices
to this pie we'll go back but if we take
region and put it onto tool tip it's not
at a low enough level for that tool tip
to make any sense so it's going to put
that star you see region is star that's
because this section of the pie covers
multiple regions if we filtered the
region to just central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when
at all levels it doesn't make any sense
but we won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines
is a big part of what determines how
many slices you get the level of detail
for the whole chart is a big factor as
well on how many slices you get great
profit by region profit by category by
subcategory and by
profit over time and we have
our category filter we don't have our
subcategory filter yet we grabbed
category but let's right click on
subcategory and click show filter there
we go now we have a filter for category
and subcategory
here's our region one
we have region in two places and we
don't want that
we wanted to apply to all of them we'll
do that when we get to the dashboard
and
we have category year of order date and
subcategory great those are all the
filters i wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once i get it set
to the size i want
profit we'll start with profit by
region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that
some different space have this at the
bottom
have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up
next to it so let's again drag it over
to the side it's always good to pay
attention to the highlighted section and
it gives you kind of an idea oh you see
i accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when i grabbed this i didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all these
and they happen to be inside the same
section you can come and click select a
layout container and now i'm grabbing
all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what i'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area i'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category
legend applies to both this chart and
this chart so that's very nice and this
subcategory legend i won't make floating
i'll just put here by subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give
our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles make these
drop downs now um because i didn't have
to on
this chart and this chart change profit
to dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
i recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so i like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so i take it the
second to the top and i drag the top one
down and then um category above
subcategory just for logical sense
excellent and we have our profit
dashboard let's see there is this check
box down here called show dashboard
title so if we wanted to have the title
at the top here you can click that
button any floating objects
don't shift down
like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title
that's up to you excellent so at this
point we have our overall dashboard that
looks at sales and profit we have our
sales dashboard and we have our profit
dashboard our profit dashboard isn't 100
complete because i forgot to make sure
all of these filters apply to all of
these worksheets so let's go ahead and
do that right now
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook and you
can see the rest here so if you wanted
all on the dashboard and you wanted this
one or something like that then you have
the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one
year this area chart becomes a lot less
useful but if you're looking at two or
more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard
to our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action
so you can make an action
on
a worksheet
you can see right here
actions or on a dashboard actions so
since we're linking between two
dashboards this is going to be a
dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made and you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and define an action it
was made by
clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action
or when we look on our sales dashboard
we clicked on this uses filter button so
we should have several actions here that
were all generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions
when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use this filter a highlight
action that we can see from here in
region and go to url action that we
haven't used if you have any questions
about go to url please post them in the
comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a url here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in a url
here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
url that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information it can get pretty cool
okay but we want to
link from this dashboard to one of our
other dashboards and you actually do
that using a filter action so we're
going to name that action
go
to
sales dashboard
and we want it to happen when we click
on our sales sheet so you see right here
it shows us the two sheets that are on
this dashboard when we click on the
profits dashboard we don't want this
action to occur this is our go to sales
dashboard now you can have an action
occur on hover
or select you've seen select happen
that's what our filter uses filter
actions use and on menu so we're going
to do it on menu
and
the targeted sheets it defaults to this
dashboard saying when i click on this i
want the rest of this dashboard to
update but instead it's going to take us
to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this i want these
sheets to update
now we're going to define what filters
it's going to apply by default it's
going to apply all of the filters based
on what we click so if we click here it
will filter to just 2013 let's say we
click here it'll filter to just 2013 and
it will filter to the region we selected
so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when i click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and west go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now
so
we can get here for that information and
to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here
go to sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now
that happens because
it's trying to pass region information
to that dashboard
but this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select what fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and
let me go back to that
we click order date year and it goes to
the target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this
okay and we're going to add one more
we're going to add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay
if
one dashboard has region in it and the
other dashboard doesn't have region in
it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard what if
we
take out region
remove region and we're just doing it
based on year
okay okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is
so now
it will filter back to the year that you
selected so this is all 2013
but it will not filter to the region you
selected
so even when we come here and we select
west
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to west
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to
sales
let's make one for profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing
where it's only going to filter it to
the year now you can see oh i started to
type in i didn't show you this before
but you can search text so i started
typing in year and it shows you that
under order date you have all these
different options in this dashboard
right now if you remember we're using
the continuous one that is marked by
the little calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just
trading it like a discrete field
okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do
is for west here we can select
both years i'm i'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click
go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016 so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could
put a note in the tooltip for this
that this doesn't work for region
linking from this area doesn't work or
perhaps you could not have this total
line on the same visualization you could
have a separate visualization that shows
the total or an area chart instead and
that will let you not have this problem
of go to sales dashboard not linking
appropriately
so now we're going to create our final
dashboard our segment dashboard and it's
going to use
a parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit
and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or ok and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same if we go forward again
segment analysis and profit and sales by
segment that allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make
a profit in sales it's going to be a
bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet consumer corporate and
home office and then we're going to look
at it segment and we're going to make a
matrix with category and we get to fill
in this space with our
visualizations so we're going to do
sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations
but we want just one so let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
it's nice and easy when the two marks
cards are based on a different measure
to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on
a bar chart now if we had profit in
front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales another way you can fix it
say you wanted the profit access to over
here for some reason you can right click
on the axis and put mark type or oh move
marks to front
another way to change it we don't need
both of these so let's not show that
header and we don't need this to be
labeled profit because it's for both of
them so the way you get rid of that is
actually you click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title
and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes
and we have three sets of bar charts
across excellent the next chart we're
going to build oh so right now they are
it automatically added the colors based
on measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them is named
profit one of them's named sales and we
know that you can come here click color
and hit edit colors and it will open
this dialog box but you can also come
here and double click on a color pops
open that dialog box let's
pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20
let's pick colors from this palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever when you make it more opaque
you start to be able to see through your
circles
there are benefits but also drawbacks to
doing that
anyway
so stick with the tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top
customers
by sales and this is where we're going
to use our parameter where we made our
top end customers so
let's bring in our sum of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set now
so we have our in and our out we're
going to break up our set
by our segment as it's part of our
segment analysis and we'll bring in our
customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for
our users of this dashboard they're like
in and out of top end customers by sales
maybe we want this to say something a
little bit more user-friendly so let's
make a calculated field and we're going
to call it the top and customers
label
and we're going to go and say if
and we're going to use our set top end
customers by sales and since it's an in
their outset it treats this like
if it's in top end customers by sales
then
top
we're going to
um do a straight so it's going to be top
and then we want to use the number
that's in our parameters so we have to
convert it from a number to a string and
we have to concatenate them together in
tableau you can use a plus sign top and
always make sure you have space between
what you're concatenating together
that's something that i tend to forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in this set then top blank
customers
else if it's not in the set we will just
call it other and in tableau you always
need to end your if statement with an
end here it tells us our calculation is
valid while we're here i want to show
you a little trick there's this arrow
button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau
and it even sorts it out by different
categories so if we didn't know how to
make this into a string we could go to
type conversion we could click on string
and it gives you an example also when
you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then i clicked on string and
i'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of tableau also in tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press dash
or
slash
and type in
this is a more user-friendly title hit
okay and there we go we have our more
user-friendly title we drag it here we
see our top 20 customers and other and
we don't want to show this anymore but
we still want it in place you can click
right click on it up here and click show
header and it hides it so that in out is
still happening there and let's drag it
to our filters and there we have it we
have our top link customers and it tells
you right there how many and we need to
come here to parameter right click and
click show parameter control and that's
how we can control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's drive profit on color and you can
see this person has a negative amount of
profit despite their big sales so that's
important for us to know and we can
change our color like we did previously
to go from red to blue
and we can
change our center to zero
and now we can see the negatives really
quickly
now they're not the only one neither
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to
show in or out we just are going to
allow them to show how many but we do
want to be able to have them filter by
category so let's show that filter and
by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen it is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its legend and total customers
by sale and it pops up with its legends
and filters and it pops up with its
parameter now i'm gonna close that and
be like if you don't see your parameter
when you first bring it in the parameter
is affecting this sheet and you can go
to parameters and find it but parameters
are
workbook wide meaning that it's going to
exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if i i've changed it to 10
and if i come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why i should name my sheets
let's see if i can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in cheat 13
we have our top 10. so i've got a 10 and
i've got a 10 over there and if i change
it to 20
and i go back to my segment dashboard
it is also changed to 20. so it will
affect all sheets always very important
to know great so here's our
visualization
here are some of the more useful legends
so
let's
make this floating and put it over by
the visualization it matters for we can
do the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these affect
all the dashboards in the
workbook again we don't have to do this
for our parameter
it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole
workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
um including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select
number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
developers
that's using parameters in a dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
tableau we talked about how to install
tableau public and how to connect to a
data source
we also talked about creating calculated
fields
like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between dashboards now let's discuss the
difference between a live connection and
an extract connection first it's
important to note that these different
types of connections are not available
in tableau public it's always a live
connection and a live connection is
where the data will update based on when
the source of the data updates so if any
if you're connected to a database and
something in the database changes then
you'll pick up those changes when you
open the report as it will query that
database
when the report is opened whereas an
extract connection
is extracted into creates a subset of
the data that improves performance so
when you're looking at it locally on
your computer you have an extract of
that data set that subset of the data
right on your computer or up in tableau
server depending on where you're looking
at it and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when your refresh updates it so
without a refresh set for that extract
you won't get the new data as an example
of this let's say
that in our
sample superstore we have kelly williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
sarah smith
and
we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in over
here in our extract it sarah smith
doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day or once every
several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau so here we have the people table
but let's say we want to join it to our
orders information so i'm going to start
with our orders table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what
two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side
and the people side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join a right join and a full outer
join let's review quickly what these
look like so say we had two tables that
we wanted to join together one of them
was the student table that had the
student names and the key
to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade a b c d f and incomplete
we can see here that somebody has made a
mistake
and put in a letter grade instead of the
key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take
the rows where the join could complete
so
we have one that could join to one just
fine but we don't have two and we don't
have three a doesn't join to anything so
this row would be not included and then
four
five and six would all join so that
would look something like this where we
would see adam
when we grab student from this table and
grade from this table we can see adam
had an a beverly had an a dale had a d
elizabeth had an f and frank is
incomplete and charles is missing also
you don't see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join
it's going to take everything
from the left table
and only the pieces from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar to our inner join
only charles shows up so the join wasn't
able to complete since a doesn't exist
in grade but we include charles anyways
and grade
becomes null
for charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and never tolerance no we look
up a inside the grade key perfect right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table so it grabs all the
grades a b c d f and incomplete and only
the rows from the left table that join
appropriately
so since charles doesn't join
appropriately he doesn't show up we also
have b and c showing up
even though it doesn't exist in the
student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables
whether or not the join is complete so
we have all of the people where the join
completes we also have charles where the
join doesn't complete from the left to
the right and we have b and c where the
join doesn't complete from the right to
the left
so those are our options in tableau
here
in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is
not in
the people table that's when you would
do a left join
for our purposes
we'll do an inner join now let's say
we had a second
excel sheet here
that had more
orders and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders by
dragging that second orders table
right underneath the original orders
table you can see it says their drag
table to union and that's helpful for if
you have an excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders and then
add the rows instead of the columns
for the 2016 orders
for example we've added people
but as a join and that will
first put in all of our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order
columns so it would have the same data
the same order id ship date but we
wanted to add more rows then that would
be one new union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by sub category and
category
we also have
percentage of total sales a long table
down so the difference between these two
things are one of them is made using
a calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales which basically makes the database
find the total
sum of sales regardless of
these dimensions we pulled on
so it gives us our total number so this
will be sum of sales for bookcases and
this will be sum of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one
percentage of total sales along table
down is what's called a table
calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done
in tableau
it's processed locally right inside of
the table after the aggregations have
occurred
there are some pros and cons of doing it
this way so
for
this percent of total sales
i had to create the table calculation
here
and it does the fixed
sum of sales where it finds the sum of
sales for the entire database and since
it is fixed it will ignore filters so
for example
i took off both of the sales and i'm
just going to put on the percent sum of
sales and let's say we wanted to see
how
office supplies and technology
are as percentages of sum of sales
and ignore furniture so we can grab
category and we'll control
click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit ok
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
100
whereas
if we take
sales
and double click it and it adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation
and click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match and that's
because it does take into account the
filter of category so let's pull the
filter of category off and we can see
that they're both out of 100 now and
each of these take into account
um
the same amount of data since we have no
filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table
then you need to use a table calculation
however when you push the information
back to the database to do the
calculation it's doing it as part of the
query to the data source and it can save
you some time and so which one of these
is faster sort of depends on
what data is available already when the
original query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
tableau
first let's add a second data source so
we can do that by coming up to data and
clicking new data source
or you can just click this plus data
source right here and click microsoft
excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store
pull on sales
and we will rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them
based on who had the highest sales to
the lowest sales we could create a
calculated field
called ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank
function
and we're going to put in sales now we
receive this error here so when we hover
we see what that arrow says oh you can
click and it says all fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated
so
we can make sum
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when i click on rank it
will tell us that it returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row
and it says identical values are
assigned an identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on rank by sales now
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one
d is next and c and b are tied 20 and 20
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place
but now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these
we'll click duplicate
and edit
let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click ok double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five
it goes one two three four
so it doesn't include that gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe i want it to be in the order i
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that will move sales to the front
and we put ranked dents at the bottom so
now we can see sales we can see rank by
sales we rank dense by sales
now let's duplicate
and
look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that i
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and look at what it
says here click on ring modified and it
says it returns the modified competition
rank where identical values are assigned
an identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place
they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same ring
here but they receive the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank unique
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two
three four and five
so what it's doing is
let's quickly
look here so
rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it
ascending or descending that means that
do we want to rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you will
define so it defaults to descending and
it's saying the biggest is the best
so
in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do for
and it's doing that based on the ascii
values
of
the store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase b comes
before lowercase c uppercase b is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data
and we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before
in our tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask and the simply learn team will get
you that data set so let's make a chart
where we're going to look at
category so we'll drag category onto
columns and then we're going to look at
sales so we'll drag sales onto rows and
it will create three bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
onto rows again
and let's
take
subcategory and bring it onto color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color
and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to
move from the sales by category sheet to
the sales by subcategory sheet and also
filter down that sheet to only the
category we want to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list
and what sheets do we want to affect
we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other
data source if we click rank example it
will show the rank example data source
so we just want sales by category to be
the source sheet
and the target sheet we want it to be
sales by subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available
to create this filter and hit ok so now
we have our go to sub category on select
we'll hit ok again
and let's
make this a little wider so we can see
and so when we click on furniture it
will take us to only furniture of the
sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make tableau drill to a lower
level
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions you can see that we have the
action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category 2.
let's say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category 2.
and hit ok
and hit ok
now when we go to worksheet actions
you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory
great so we have our sales by category
two let's bring it to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories
in the colors there
now we can take a look
here
and sort by
subcategory based on some of sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each sub category that's just
a way that i like to view it so
let's do a highlight action and we're
going to do it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory
and look at it over top of our sales by
category stacked over top of sales by
sap category so we want both of those
let's make our
dashboard automatic for
testing purposes
and we'll go to dashboard we'll click
create actions so we're going to add an
action it's going to be a highlight
action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by
subcategory be the target sheet for all
fields okay
okay and on select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
i want to see all these small ones or i
want to see
this one and these small ones or
whatever then it will highlight the ones
that you drag and select now this is
also true of our sales by subcategory
and sales by category so when we clicked
on technology it filtered to just
technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click
office supplies and technology we get
office supplies and technology now if we
go back to the dashboard we can see that
this dashboard is now filtered also to
office supplies and technology and
that's because we're using the same
sheet
and when you navigate away from that
sheet it doesn't mean that your filter
goes away
so when i clicked undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so if
you're going to have two
things affect that sheet
just remember that just because you
navigated away from what you selected
doesn't mean that what you selected goes
away that filter will stay there and it
shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a url action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so i'm going to double click state
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a field
map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put state onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label
so we can see the sales amount let's
quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're going to
lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on
great so now we have our sales map and
we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and the
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to url
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet
sheet 6 which we should rename and we're
going to have a url in here so this will
take us to wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
wikipedia
so
we're going to take state and add it to
the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up
okay click ok let's rename our sheet to
url
filter by state
and so when we click on texas
okay back to url filter by state let's
go to our worksheets
and go to our actions and on the go to
sub category
it is also affecting this url filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here and sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it won't auto select no sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on wiki and it
will open up
our browser with the wikipedia page for
texas this can become really handy in
the event that you have data that maybe
has an order id and you can take that
order id and insert it into a url in
your system so that it can take you to
your web interface page for that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of california
which
it can have information about the
languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the webpage right inside of
tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to url action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this url won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on oklahoma
it'll open up a page for oklahoma
but let's unselect oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit ok and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on oklahoma
instead of taking us to oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to texas and this will change to texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
lines
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics pane
and it is something that comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so
let's make
um our visualization we'll do our
category
and sub category again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it onto text that's not
what i want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to analytics
and we code to drag our reference line
onto
our visualization it says you can add
the reference line for the whole table
for a pane or for a cell
so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to define our cell
so each one of these
if we drag our reference line onto
so
each one of them gets a reference line
you see how it added those on this is
our dialog box we will look at that in
just a moment
so let's remove that if we take
reference line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to have a
category on a color so each of these
different colors
is now a pain reference line onto pane
and you see how we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it onto table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do
find out the average for each
section
so i'm going to take category put it
back onto color and we'll take reference
line and put it onto pain
now we have our reference line it's
based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it was taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs
so taking an average across these added
up sections
we could also have it be
total
where it's adding all of these up and
that makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case
a constant which is where you get to
define the value and so if we wanted it
to be
hundred
thousand there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average
or the median so let's stick with
average and now you can see it's
labeling the line as average we could
also have it label the line as the value
so now we can see that the average is
this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon
and then the value average
this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
ok
and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our
recalculated
average line
so the average for tables for just
tables
is the sum divided by the number so the
sum of tables is 206 96 divided by 1 is
still 2 6 9 66 so selecting just tables
is really helpful but if we wanted to
know the average of
tables and we'll control click
appliances
and we'll control click binders oh there
we go
all three of those are selected we can
see the average of those three which is
this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those
five categories
and those are reference lines
now let's duplicate this sheet
and i'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
bands
click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pane or per cell so
let's do a reference band for the whole
table so it's doing entire table
and it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum now we could change the minimum
to be the average to the maximum and now
that will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to
average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you can add lines so we have a line
for the average or the maximum you can
make it thinner you can make it dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray and you can have
show recalculated band for highlighted
or you can remove that and that way when
we highlight stuff everything just stays
where it belongs for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making
several different kinds of
visualizations such as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learn team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to
look at it by state
and we're going to look at it by
ship mode
and so we'll take average stasis ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's
change the order of these really quick
if we come up here to ship mode and we
click sort we click manual we can have
same day above first class so that it
kind of goes in order of priority so
same day first class second class
standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do
if
the
average days to ship is less than or
equal to two
then
we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't uh
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're going to call it
an early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five then shipment
late
and
else if let's get the rest of them
and
average days to ship is
not less than two
greater than two
and less than
five
then
on time
two words
on time and now you can see we have an
error here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement
if statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it on to color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment
as orange
and shipment lane as red
we could double click on the color and
we can change shipment early to green
and now we can see
the best ones the on time ones and the
ones that stand out as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the district of columbia
has second class as a legit late
shipment
you can see that all of these
share
the same axis size so they all go from
zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to six
if we click edit axis
you can choose if you want that to be
the case so it's like right now all of
them use uniform access range for all
rows and columns and that's really nice
because it's easy to compare
colorado to colorado to colorado if you
change it to independent access for each
rose you can see now this one only goes
from zero to not even one whereas this
one goes from zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart
based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall
looks like at the end and talk about how
it works so after we build it we'll talk
about some of the benefits of having a
waterfall chart so what we're going to
do is build it over time for this
visualization we're just going to look
at the year of 2014 so i'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month so you can see that i
chose the one that has month and year
and then when i chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from
profit
to
our
running total of profit
so you can see that it takes january and
then it adds february to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to we only have our running total
where it will some january and february
for the february mark and then some
january february march for the march
mark
if i take profit
and put it here you can see january is
negative three thousand and february is
positive two thousand but here it's the
sum of those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a gantt bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have
we're going to call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit
with the negative sign in front
oh it looks like i've done this before
so
now we have a new name because i added a
space at the end so hit apply
and let's um delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit
and we're going to use that to determine
the size
of the grant bar
so
what it does
is it takes where the line was and it
adds the size of it to be the size of
profit but because the line was at the
top and we didn't want to build the
profit up we had to change it to
negative profit so it would build it
down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns it orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are november
and march november being a little bit
bigger
and you can see where we started at the
beginning of that month and where we
ended and that's how a waterfall chart
works so it lets you go through over
time and see exactly where our problems
were
and exactly which months helped the most
where we started and where we ended for
each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order
id and it's going to add all members but
then i'm going to change order id
from a dimension to
a measure and we have account distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see
one person has 17 orders and we have
1 2
3 4
5 6 7
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers
had how many orders and what number of
orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so
in order to do this
we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us
the number of orders per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer
so let's call this orders
per
customer and we'll come here and we're
going to use a level of detail
calculation called fixed
now there are
two other level of detail calculations
and they are called
include and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in
some of our simply learn classes and if
you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them so we're
going to do it fixed
and you can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name so we're going to
have fixed customer name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order id
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors and
we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so
let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see
one two three four five six seven eight
up to 17. so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers ordered 17 and we had them
order everything in between so if we'd
never had a customer that had nine
orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer
id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto roast and we're
going to change it to a measure
and it's going to be
account distinct
and so now we can see
how many customers ordered
how many items so
we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per
customer
perfect
now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to
do an analysis about new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time
we're going to
use these
so that it makes an axis
instead of just
change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous and then we're going
to take our customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
[Music]
account distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day i think day is too low of a level
let's go at month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
we click on central we can see central
now this is including all customers
but say we only wanted to include a
customer when they're making their very
first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
to their first order date the min
order date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together so we're
going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of trying to return
something different based on the
visualization it will always return the
min for each customer id
so if the order date on the
visualization is equal to this order
date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else
existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that it's a
new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date
apply
okay and now we can take our new field
which is new or existing and drag it
onto filters and we only want new
we'll hit apply
and we can see that we have new
customers
but
less over time
so
so now we're going to change this count
distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how
our new customers are adding up so it's
taking the prior value and adding our
new customers and then at the end we get
our total customers for each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day
and you can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then here for
the region of east there kind of is a
level spot where we're not getting new
orders
and that seems to be the same for each
of them so for february of 2014 why were
we not getting any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster
it's leveling out in the red
it looks like the west region
leveled out as well but picked up sooner
and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view
new customers over time and it's only
possible because we were able to do a
level of detail calculation
here on new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here
so those are a couple of ways that level
of detail calculations can be very
helpful
in summary today we learned about
live versus extract tableau
data sources we learned about joins and
unions in the data sources we also
looked at table versus database
calculations we looked at how the
different ranks compare
we built some actions into our
dashboards filter actions and
highlighting actions we also looked at
url actions we built dashboards that
used reference lines and ones that use
reference bands we did analyzing of
average days to ship
and delay analysis
we built a waterfall chart
and we also looked into some level of
detail calculations my name is michelle
and i'm with the simply learn team today
we'll be going over answers to common
interview questions for tableau
positions first question is what are the
data types supported in tableau we have
string date date and time numerical
boolean so true or false and
geographical in tableau you can tell
what kind of data type you have so when
you're on the data source tab you can
see that this is numerical and this is
string here we have a date we don't have
any date times here that would have the
little clock icon and we also have
geographical these are set by default
and you can change them by clicking on
the icon
and say we wanted row id to allow text
so we'll change it to string and you can
see the icon changes there the next
question has to do with how will you
understand dimensions and measures so a
key thing to remember is that dimensions
are qualitative and measures are
quantitative and if you can remember
those particular words it helps convey
what the interviewer is looking for so
dimensions are qualitative and you can
use them to categorize your data so for
example you can categorize your data by
what country it comes from and measures
are quantitative and can be aggregated
so you can do a sum of sales or you can
do the average profit did you know that
tableau automatically assigns each field
a data type and a role and that
automatically aggregates your measures
using sum but you can change what the
default aggregation is question three
what do you understand by discrete and
continuous in tableau so we have
discrete values and continuous values
discrete is represented as blue and
continuous is represented as green so
let's look in tableau when we go to our
worksheet
you can see that all the dimensions are
automatically blue
and all of the measures are green
however you can have a continuous
dimension and you can have a discrete
measure
so we have discrete dimensions which is
a blue dimension but also continuous
dimensions and data is a good example of
that let's take a look so we pull on
order date we right now have year
and it's making categories instead of a
continuous axis so it's making a finite
list there but we can change it to be
you can see now it's marked as
continuous here and it's green and we
change it to be an axis
instead of different categories it would
be a continuous axis
so you can also have discrete measures
which are blue measures and continuous
measures in the green so for example
let's say we had a visualization that
had
the region
and
sales
and profit
but instead of having an axis for profit
maybe we just wanted to have
a number for the profit listed right
next to
the region and then we could have the
sales visualization so what we could do
is change it to a discrete
value and put it next to region and now
it's part of the labels and that's an
example of having a discrete
measure
did you know that
continuous is infinite and discrete is
finite those are some key words that you
could use
also to describe the difference between
continuous and discrete and also just
remember that discrete is blue and
continuous is green the next question
number four is what are filters and name
the different filters in tableau so
filters are a way to restrict the data
that allows you to only see the data
that you want to see in your workbook or
dashboard and there are these different
types of filters and they also have a
specific order so if you can remember
the different filters that's helpful but
also if you can remember what order they
apply in that'll get you some definite
bonus points in your interview we have
extract filters that filter the data as
it extracts and it will affect how big
your extract is we also have data source
filters here which will filter the data
out of the data source however the
extract will still be the same size so
let's take a look at this handy
visualization
that tableau has on their website we
have the order of operations and in blue
we have our filters
so extracts is first and it filters down
your extract to just what you've
selected then we have data source
filters that will apply to the entire
data source so any visualization that
uses that data source will have these
filters we also have context filters
which are next which come before
some of these level of details that's
the major difference is that it applies
before some of these sets and
conditional values and then you will do
dimensions and then measures so any
filters that happen on dimensions happen
before any measure filters the last type
of filter we have is a table calculation
filter which happens after all of the
rest of them and basically just applies
to
your visualization just the one
visualization question number five there
are three customer segments in the super
store data set what percent of the total
profits is associated with the corporate
segment perfect so in some tableau
interviews you may be asked to build a
visualization for our examples here
we'll be using the superstore data set
and if you don't have access to the
superstore data set just comment below
and somebody on the simply learn team
will help you get access to that also
this is a fun opportunity to pause the
video and then you can work on this on
your own and then come back and see if
what you did was the right thing or how
we did it differently also you can
comment below on what your answer is and
we'll see if we can all get the right
thing
so let's build this three customer
segments in the super store data set
what percent of the total profits total
profits is associated with corporate
segment great so we're going to bring on
our segments and we have consumer
corporate and home office and let's
bring on our
total profit so i just did that by
double clicking and now it's just
bringing on the sum for each of those by
default but we want to figure out what
percent of the total each of these are
so we can change this to be
a table calculation we can click add
table calculation or we can do a quick
table calculation
and find percent of total so let's go
back to our question we wanted to know
the percent of total profits associated
with the corporate segment and the
corporate segment has
32.12 percent of the total profits and
here's our solution with
32.12 percent so did you get it right
comment below if you got that what are
the different joins in tableau give an
example
so in tableau
you can join your data so if we wanted
to look at orders and tie it to
people we could pull on people and it
will give you this visualization and you
can see all the different joins here and
we'll discuss those in just a second you
also have the opportunity to union
information which would be if we had
maybe two excel sheets that had orders
information perhaps one of them had 2012
and one of them had 2013 then you could
take your orders and pull it so you see
that pop-up drag table to union and
that's another way to add more data and
so those are all worth mentioning let's
take a look at the different kinds of
joins
we have our inner join which will only
give you the values that have matches in
both tables
our left join that will give you all the
values in the left table and its matches
in the right table
and then the right join which will give
you all the values in the right table
and its matches in the left table
the outer join also known as a full
outer join will give you all the values
in the left and the right table and then
as we discuss the union you can see it's
represented by a more vertical join and
what it does is it adds more rows all
the rest of these are about adding more
columns but this will add more rows
in the same columns that you had before
if you have the opportunity to draw out
the answer to this question and make
these venn diagrams it's a really
helpful way for you to explain your
point and it really portrays that you
know what you're talking about what is
the difference between a join and
blending in tableau so i just showed you
how to make a join here and we are
joining
an excel sheet to another excel sheet
all within the same connection to that
excel file so when you're joining data
we'll look over here at the joining side
that's when you're bringing two or more
tables within the same data source and
that's how you join it and so
we're all inside of a data source here
which when i go to sheet 1 just has one
data source here called orders whatever
we wanted to call it and that is all
within one data source however let's say
we already had two different data
sources in tableau and we wanted to
bring together two of them so in this
case it's an oracle table and we brought
in an oracle table and we made a data
source and then also an excel table that
had a second data source and you can
blend it together to get your combined
data set so the major difference what
you're going to really want to take away
from this is that blending is from two
separate tableau data sources and that
joining is all within one data source
and it ends up just being one data
source in the end in blending each data
source contains its own set of
dimensions and measures and when you
join it will combine it into one set of
dimensions and measures so let's go back
to our example here let's bring on
people it is automatically said we're
going to join it on region and we're
going to do an inner join that's fine by
me
and so we come here
and now we have just one
set of dimension and measures under
orders however if we were to add a
second data source which we will it'll
be an excel file and it will be based
off of this rank example
we'll open that up and now when we go to
sheet one we have two data sources
and if we were to blend this data
together we would still see two separate
sets of data only we would be able to
pull in from this set some information
and we'd pull in from this set some
other information so that's a visual
difference between blending and joining
question number eight is what is the
difference between a live and an extract
so first we'll talk about live and we'll
say that your dashboard is connected
live to a database and so a live
connection will query that database
every time you open up the dashboard or
visualization so that you're getting the
most recent information each time and
it's useful for if you need information
that's a little bit more real time
however it can be slower especially if
your queries are complicated with an
extract it will run the query beforehand
and store the information on tableau
server or on your local machine and so
that it's faster to get to however it is
not real-time information so if you had
a refresh of your extract that runs
every day in the morning and then during
the day somebody has made a change to
your database they won't see that change
on your dashboard until the next time
the refresh runs for your extract in
tableau
you can set
if you want the connection to be live or
extract
when you first are making your data
source and this is a tableau desktop in
tableau
public you don't have that option did
you know that
the reason that extracts are faster is
because tableau doesn't need to access
the database each time it fills the
visualization and did you know that you
can set up a refresh schedule on tableau
server in order to be able to see your
extracted data update question 9 what is
a calculated field and how will you
create one so if we look at our data set
here
we have the opportunity to see the
difference between order date and ship
date so to create a calculated field
you click create calculated field with
this drop down arrow at the top or you
can right click in white space
create calculated field
then you give it a name
and we're going to call it
shipping delay
and we are going to do
a date diff
so if you don't see this dialog box here
you can click this arrow
to see that
our date part is day the start date is
order date and end date is ship date
so to remember how to create a
calculated field it's by clicking this
down arrow and clicking create
calculated field
and then writing your
query here
and a calculated field is an additional
field made up using the data that you
already have so
we've made a new field here and it has
the equal sign at the beginning that
might be worth mentioning how to tell if
it's a calculated field or if it was an
original field and then we can bring a
shipping delay
here and we can see the number of days
that it took between the order date and
the ship date
we could also
duplicate a calculated field so now we
have shipping delay copy
and we're going to call this
average shipping delay
and we're going to encapsulate it
inside an average function
and now if we take off the order id the
order date and the ship date
it's automatically summing up those days
but we can bring on our average shipping
delay
and you can see on average how many days
it took
and let's change
our number here to
include decimal places
so a calculated field is a new field
made from existing data
it can be used to create more robust
visualizations and it does not affect
the original data set for example we
made our average delay function here
using data from our original data set
question 10 how can you display top five
and last five sales in the same view
you can show top five and last five
sales for a same dimension by creating a
set
so let's take a look at doing that here
we have
our customers so let's bring on customer
name
and we're going to do it based on profit
so now that we've done it on profit we
can see these are our top five profit
and i've sorted it by profit
and
here's our bottom five
and we can create a set by coming and
clicking on the dimension that we want
the set to be based on we'll right click
there and we will
come to create and click set
now we're going to call this top
customers
top by field top five
five sum of profit and now we have a set
it makes a set section here
now we're going to make a second set
off of customer name
create set
bottom customers
bottom
5 by
sum of profit we'll hit ok and now we're
going to combine these two sets so i'm
going to control click and then we have
both of them selected and we're going to
click create combined set
top and bottom
customers
and we're going to have it include all
members of both sets
and now we can pull top and bottom
customers onto filters and you can see
our top five and our bottom five so if
we
control drag profit onto color
then it's colored by that as well so key
thing to remember is that you can use it
sets to create to show both the top and
the bottom in the same visualization and
that you can combine those sets
is there a difference between sets and
groups in tableau the answer to this is
yes
you can describe a group as being
simpler and using only one dimension to
determine the group whereas a set can be
more complex so you could say sets are
more complex and you can use conditions
to create the sets and you can also use
multiple dimensions and measures to
create the sets
for example here we create a group of
subcategory so we grab all of these
things together and can group it and
that will be
we'll have copiers and envelopes and
then we'll have one group
of all of these together over here you
could create a set
that looks at sales and profits to
create its set so the best way i can
describe this is by looking at what we
did here and so we were able to use
dynamic
filtering here to create our sets
and where we'll look at the top five or
the bottom five and let's do the same
thing we did there but use a group so
for a group we could see that these
we've sorted it and we can say
one two three
four five this is the top five so we
could create
a group that's this paper clip here and
now we have a group of the top five and
it's added that group it makes a new
group customer name group and it put it
on the color for us now let's go to the
bottom and we're going to go one two
three four five and we'll create
our group
so now we have a top five group at
bottom five group so let's name them
that and we'll do that by clicking edit
alias
top customers
okay and we'll come here and we'll
rename that
bottom customers
okay we'll put our top customers on top
and then let's hide all the others so
we'll click exclude there and now we
have a similar visualization as we had
before for our sets
top bottom however a key difference here
is that we had to go through and select
the top five and the bottom five so
let's say that
maybe
cindy or let's say henry goldwyn has
suddenly
had much more positive profit associated
with them if that changes he's gonna
still stay in our group this group is
just using these customer names to
determine who's in the group so the
group is henry sherrell luke grant and
cindy no matter
if their data changes so say tomorrow
all this data is different it's still
going to put these people into the group
however the sets as you saw before is
based off of the profit the sum of
profit and who has the top five and who
has the bottom five if raymond suddenly
has a lot less profit and falls out of
the group then
the groups won't pick it up but the sets
will so that's one thing to remember is
that it could be based on conditions and
then you saw how we took two sets and
put them together into our combined
group you could also have a set that is
based off of two different dimensions
or two different measures and that's how
you could put those two sets together
and get dynamic sets
so the major differences as we saw is
that a group is just based off of one
dimension
and a set can have conditions and be
based on off of other dimensions
also you need to know that groups cannot
be used in calculated fields but sets
can
question 12 what is a parameter in
tableau and give an example
a parameter is a dynamic value that a
customer could select
and you can use it to replace constant
values in calculations filters and
reference lines so for example here we
determined we wanted bottom five and top
five customers but let's give them some
options so we'll create a parameter
and we'll call it select
number of
top
bottom
customers
and we're going to
[Music]
let it be a range
with a minimum of 5
and a maximum of 20
and a step size of five so we'll let
them go five at a time
okay
now if we click show parameter control
we can see our parameter control and you
can do 5 10 15 or 20. but since it's not
in any of our calculated fields or sets
or filters then it's not making any
difference so let's put it inside of
these
we'll edit our set and instead of top or
bottom five
we'll click bottom select number of top
bottom customers so now it's taking our
parameter and inserting it in
to our set there we'll do the same thing
with top customers
okay and now right now we see top five
bottom five if we change it now we see
top ten bottom ten fifteen and there's
our twenty
so it replaces a constant value and
allows the end user to select the value
question 13 what is the difference
between tree maps and heat maps
so let's first talk about what each of
these are heat maps compare categories
using size and color i think the biggest
thing about heat maps is the color size
is somewhat optional so let's build this
visualization quickly
so
we have region
category
and subcategory
and we're making a heat map so
we want to bring profit onto color
and you can see we've got hotter and
colder in this case
for a heat map we might want to change
so in this case what it's doing is
hotter is negative but we could reverse
that and then hotter is positive and so
hotter maybe means this is where more
activity is we can also double click on
profit
we can also bring profit onto label
and we'll change this to
square and now it's marked at what
everything is so a heat map
will use color to draw your eye to the
places where there's heat or maybe
activity we could also use size in this
case so it's not just defined by color
necessarily maybe we want the size to be
defined by sales so we get things that
are bigger but they're blue which means
that they are bigger in sales but their
profit is negative and it draws your
eyes to
technology so machines in the south are
doing a lot of sales but they're not
having positive profit necessarily
also you can see some things that have
darker colors
but are smaller so high profit but not a
lot of sales so that is a heat map a
tree map is used to represent
hierarchical data now hierarchy is the
term you need to remember when you're
talking about the difference between a
tree map and a heat map
in the heat map none of these boxes have
to do with the hierarchy with each other
whereas with a tree map you can see that
this box has a thick white line between
it and the other ones and that means
that that section
are all connected so these are all
technology
and the bigger this section is that
means the bigger the let's see size is
based off of profit so this bigger
section means that technology has more
profit than furniture so let's build
this one when i build tree maps i like
to use our show me tool so here's tree
map and it says one or more dimensions
or one and one to two measures so we're
gonna grab category and we're going to
control click sub category and we're
going to control click profit and
sales and we'll click on our tree map
perfect and so the darker the color
that means the more sales there is and
that's pretty similar to our heat map
over here so the color indicated
in this case it was profit so the color
indicates the difference and the size
indicates the difference and that's true
over here the color indicates a
difference and the size indicates a
difference however there is a hierarchy
to it over here you can see that there
is um hierarchies because we have
furniture and then that puts that all
together under furniture
and then here's the subcategories
however if you were trying to compare
furniture to office supplies it's really
difficult to tell which one has more
sales but if we go over to sheet 7 that
has our tree map on it you can see
really quickly that office supplies has
much more sales than furniture in this
case office supplies has much more
profit than furniture biggest difference
is that tree maps have the hierarchy
question number 14 what is the
difference between twb
and twb so these are all
tableau file formats and the twbx
contains all of the unnecessary
information to build the visualization
so it's called a packaged workbook and
it compresses it all together however
the twb just contains instructions about
how to interact with the data source so
when it's building a visualization
tableau will look at the data source and
then build the visualization with an
extract it contains all of the
information that you need so all the
data is wrapped up inside of there and
there's no connection that has to be
made between tableau and the data source
because it's all right inside whereas
with the twb it has to connect to the
data source or else it doesn't have the
data to build the visualizations it just
knows it has the instructions of what to
do with that data so the biggest
difference is twbx has the data inside
of it whereas a twb only has the
instructions question 15 explain the
difference between tableau worksheet
dashboard story and workbook perfect
here's a breakdown and explanation of
each of those and in tableau this entire
thing that we've been looking at all
these sheets
is a workbook
however this sheet 7 is just one
worksheet all of them together is a
workbook and sheet 7 is a worksheet
the big difference between a worksheet
and a dashboard is that the worksheet is
just one
visualization and so it is only one set
of columns and rows here at a dashboard
could contain multiple visualizations so
if we wanted to see our heat map and our
tree map
on the same page that would be a
dashboard and then a story
is somewhat similar
to a presentation mode and so you can
have different pages and so we could say
here is our
heat map and then we could make another
page
and look at our
tree map
and then look at our heat map
and then we could duplicate that page
and we could
say let's focus on furniture
so we're going to highlight furniture
and then so if we were to go through
these one at a time
we would say here's our tree map and
then we would look at information there
and we would say here's our heat map and
then the next screen will say let's
focus on furniture and you can see that
it highlighted furniture for me when i
went to the next scene so a story
can show you things one at a time it's
like a presentation mode so the
differences are the workbook contains
the sheets and the dashboards of the
stories
the worksheet is a single view dashboard
is multiple views and a story is a
sequence a sequence is a good key word
to remember when you're describing a
story and did you know
that the only place that you can access
the dimensions and the measures and
custom fields we've made is on a
worksheet so when you're looking at a
dashboard
so on a worksheet we see dimensions and
measures when you're looking at a
dashboard you no longer see dimensions
and measures what you do see are all of
the worksheets similarly when you look
at a story you no longer see
any dimensions and measures but you do
see all the worksheets and the
dashboards question 16 what do you
understand by blended axis with a
blended axis you can use two measures
that share an axis and that means they
necessarily have the same scale so let's
build something with a blended axis
so we can make a visualization that
looks at
sales
over time
we'll bring on order date
and
let's just
do order date by
month there we go
so we can see sales over time and say we
wanted to
also see profit
this is two visualizations that have two
different axes but if we wanted them to
have the same axes
and just the same marks card you see how
i made two different marks cards we
could bring on
measure values
and take off all the measures that we
don't want
we just want
when we take them off here it's creating
this filter here for measure names
and let's take off these two extra
visualizations and now we have a
visualization that has a blended axes
for sales over time and profit over time
and you can see that they necessarily
have the same axes there is no second
axes
what is the use of a dual axis and how
do you create one perfect so a dual axis
allows you to compare measures and you
can have two different scales so if we
had this same visualization that same
information that we wanted to see with
again profit
and sales
over time
we'll do
okay great and we wanted them to have
the same axes we could right click on
the second pill
of the measures
and click dual axis and now you can see
that they do not share the same axis and
you can see profit is much higher here
right there and so the use of this would
be sometimes you need things to have
different axes
if you come here and you click
synchronize axes you end up getting a
pretty similar visualization but you do
get two separate marks cards
so a key thing to bring up if you are
asked the difference between a blended
axis and a dual axis chart
is one that the blended axis uses the
same scale and a dual axis could have
two different scales and two a dual axis
has two marks cards so let's say we
wanted our profit
to not be a line chart but to be a bar
chart that gives you that option when
you go to the blended axis we only have
one mark's card so we change it to bar
everything is bar
but back over here we change it to
circles and we see the circles
so if we wanted to show sales by year
and profit ratio by year in the same
view that's where two different scales
could be handy let's build that
visualization
so we'll make a new chart and we'll
bring on sales
and
profit ratio
over time
that is profit i still did profit so
i'll drag profit ratio right over top of
profit there we go and you can see that
they can't use the same scale because
this is a percentage and so
um if we had them on a blended axis 20
percent is really 0.2 and it would just
be so tiny
but if we wanted them on the same area
to act to apply to the same space here
we could dual access it that you can
still see useful information there but
otherwise this would just be in such a
tiny tiny space
so our profit ratio would just show up
right here almost like a straight line
question 18 what will the following
function return left three comma tableau
here's the question again
and here are the potential answers tab
or eau error or none of the above so
just take a moment and see if you can
answer this question correctly go ahead
and pause the video and if you get the
answer you can comment below and then we
will discuss
we've taken some time to
answer this question and let's go ahead
and see what the answer is the answer is
it will return an error that's because
the syntax for left is that the string
must go first first you say left then
you put the string and then you put the
number so let's talk about what left
does it returns a specific number of
characters from the left and if you had
done it correctly the left is this side
so if you had done the string first and
you said you want three the result would
be t a b
there's also one called right
and that would come from the other end
and go eau so that's where these answers
came from question 19 how do you handle
null and other special values tableau is
unable to plot null values or zeros or
negative values on a logarithmic axis
and so it will display an indicator in
the lower right corner which looks like
this
telling you that is unable to draw those
two points
so when you click on the indicator you
can choose from the following first you
can choose to filter the data which will
exclude the null values from the
visualization or you can click show data
at the default position so we'll look at
both of these
so you click on your indicator and it
will say what do you want to do with
these two values if we click filter the
data then you can see that it has
filtered those that blank space and
drawn a line connecting
those dates in between even though there
is no point for the 29th or the 30th it
goes straight from the 28th to the 31st
so what's happening on our visualization
is it's adding this filter if we press
the back button we see that filter
disappears if we come down and select
filter the data it adds a filter here
that then
only includes non-null values
so those are all removed from our
visualization and up to this point you
can see that we have one point per day
the 21st the 22nd the 23rd 24th but then
when we get to the 28th we don't have a
29th or 30th and it just draws that line
to the 31st
assuming
that during that time period
that what we want is a straight line now
the other option would be
we could also make the assumption that
whenever there is a null value that
actually means zero sales have happened
during that time so that's when you
would click show data at default
position
and now it draws those two points
at the zero line
and when you hover it still shows sales
null
so then when you hover here you can see
the actual amount for sales during that
time
so if a null in your data means zero
then show a default position is good for
you and if it doesn't necessarily mean
zero
then you can
filter the data or you can leave it
disconnected like this
question 20 find the top product
subcategories by sales within each
delivery method which subcategory is
ranked number two for first class ship
mode if you'd like to pause the video
and work on this on your own and then
see if
what you did matches what we did then
you're welcome to now at this time and
comment below what your answer is
okay so we want to know by subcategory
and by ship mode
which
subcategory ranks the highest for each
ship mode so in sales so if we take
sales
onto the visualization we can see that
by the ship mode
it's already split up and we could see
that
maybe this one for standard class it
would be chairs you can kind of look
through and kind of oh it's not chairs
chairs isn't number one because we have
this one it's phones so to make it
easier we're going to
change some of sales to a rank table
calculation so we're going to come here
and click add table calculation
and we're going to change the
calculation type to rank and it's going
to rank them
in order
of sales
so but we right now we can see that it's
highlighting that's called calculation
assistance helping us understand
how it's ranking us so if i and select
calculation assistance then it gets rid
of it but you can see right now it's
ranking it
across the table so it says accessories
has most sales in standard class then
second class then first class then same
day
and that's not what we want to see we
want to see it up and down
we want to see for first class which
subcategory has the highest sales and
second highest sales so let's turn back
on our calculation assistance and we're
going to click table down
and you can see now it's going up and
down within first class what are all the
subcategories ranked so that's what we
want
now as soon as you click things in the
table calculation it applies it over
here so you don't have an ok button
so you can just close that out
and you can see now we have a rank up
and down
for the subcategory so back to the
question was which subcategory is ranked
second for first class ship mode here's
first class let's find number two it's
chairs
question number 21 find the customer
with the lowest overall profit what is
his her profit ratio let's go ahead and
build this visualization
customer profit
and we're going to
bring all of our customers on
and then we're going to bring on profit
let's do it as a visualization so i'll
bring it on to columns and then let's
sort smallest to biggest so cindy
stewart
is the one who has our lowest profit
and now to figure out her profit ratio
we need to make a calculated field which
i've already made here
so in this calculated field we take the
sum of profit and divided by the sum of
sales we do this
so that it will sum up all of the profit
per row
so for cindy we want to take all of her
profit
over all of her transactions and divide
it by all of her sales instead of doing
it row by row profit divided by sales
profit divided by sales and then summing
that up at the end so
we'll take our profit ratio and put it
onto label
and we can see
what her profit ratio is and since it's
a ratio here i have it in a percent
if you don't have your profit ratio set
up as a percent it will look like this
negative 1.65 question number 22
what is the rank function in tableau we
got a look at the rank function earlier
when we figured out our top product
subcategories by sales and what was
ranked number two so
i'm sure you're familiar with what
ranking is which is assigning something
a position like first place or second
place usually within a category and
usually based on a measure so
tableau
is able to rank in several different
ways where you can do
rank or rank dense rake modified or rank
unique and we'll take a look at these
individualization here and talk about
the difference but if you are asked
about
the rank function in tableau it's worth
bringing up that there are several
different ways to rank and going into a
little bit of detail on those different
ways will be helpful for you so
let's
build off of this rank example instead
so we're going to bring on our store and
we've got store a b c d and e and then
we'll bring on our sales
and store a had ten dollars and e had
forty dollars
so
now let's create a calculated field
we're going to call it rank
we're going to do a rank calculated
field
based on sales
we're going to do a rank calculated
field based on sum of sales
perfect
okay
we'll double click on rank and we can
see first place is the one who had the
most sales and fifth place is the one
with the least sales now we had a tie
here at 20 and it gave them both third
place and then it skipped fourth place
and went to fifth place and that's how
the basic rank function works
so if we duplicate it
and we edit our copy
and we're going to make this one
rank dense
you know what let's do rank modified
second
okay
and we bring on rank modified
let's have this happen in order so sum
of sales then rank then rank modified
now you can see
it's similar to rank first second but
then it skips third and goes to fourth
and then fifth so over here it gave them
buyer number when there was a tie and
over here it gave them the lower number
when there was a tie
so if you could remember that
rank gives them the higher number and
rank modified gives them the lower
number that will be helpful
for your interview
now we're going to take a look at rank
dense
rank dense apply
and rank dense doesn't skip a number so
it goes one two three four and it
condenses
the ranking
without any skipping any numbers
and now let's
do our last one
which is going to be
rank unique
okay
and with rank unique it refuses to give
to
the same rank
and how it determines when there is a
tie is it will look at the dimension
that's in the visualization and do
whichever one comes first in ascii so it
goes one two and these are a tie and
since capital b comes before
lowercase c
then it's doing b first then c
then a
so in your interview it would be really
impressive to talk about the different
versions of ranks
and how they all work
question 23 how can you embed a web page
in a dashboard so we're just going to
build this and then explain it so i have
here my map by sales and we're going to
build a dashboard
we'll bring on first we'll change our
layout so i can fill up the screen
then let's bring on my map
and i've added the state name and the
sales on the map here
for
an embedded web page you can grab it
from the objects section the web page
and then you could put a url right
inside of here
and then that will embed that page
underneath
so if we wanted to do wikipedia or
something we can hit ok and it will take
you to wikipedia
but what we're going to do is make this
page dynamic based on what state you
select it'll look up that wikipedia page
for that state so you could maybe look
at some population data
we'll close that and we'll try again
we're going to bring on our web page
it's going to ask for a url but we're
just going to hit ok and not provide it
with a url
and then we'll use this dashboard action
and create a url action
that then contains our url
with our state
appended at the end which is how
wikipedia formats their url so we'll hit
okay
oh i forgot one more thing let's do it
on select instead of on menu so whenever
we select something it will run this
okay
okay and now when we select texas
it brings up the texas wikipedia page
when we select nebraska it'll change
so the major points to know on how to
embed a web page is you bring it in from
the objects section and then if they ask
how to make a dynamic you use dashboard
actions
and a url action
question 24 design a view to show
region-wide profit and sales
so one way you could do this is by
bringing on region and then bringing on
profit
and
sales
and that's a pretty simple view of
profit and sales by region however
one thing that interviewers may be
looking for when asking a question about
region is your mapping capabilities in
tableau so
what we could do
is
region is not a geographic location so
it takes a little bit of creativity but
if you bring on state by double clicking
it and it maps out the states
you can
make it a map here and it fills it in
and then you can bring region onto color
and that splits it up by region
and then if you bring on profit
and sales on the labels
and let's also bring on the state onto
labels
and then you can look at your profit and
sales inside of their regions inside of
their states
and so
that is another view where you could
look at
profit and sales by region and it's a
little bit more
takes advantage of some of the mapping
capabilities in tableau it may be what
your interviewer is looking for so you
could discuss multiple ways to look at
it but here is one way that we could
recommend it question 25 how can you
optimize the performance of a dashboard
there are multiple ways to optimize the
performance of the dashboard some of the
things that you might mention is that
you could exclude any fields you're not
using from your visualization just keep
them off or you can use extract filters
and if you recall extract filters will
remove out rows of data from the extract
and so only focus on the data that you
need another thing you can do is try and
limit the amount of filters that you use
and when you do use filters avoid using
quick filters and you can use action
filters and parameter filters instead
filters cause your queries in the
database to be a little bit more complex
and can keep
them from running as efficiently as they
could use min and max instead of average
because average functions require more
processing time than min max also you
can try to use boolean and numerical
calculations because computers do better
with integers and booleans than they do
with strings
so quick things to remember is keep your
data simple
use fewer filters and when you do use
filters use parameters or actions avoid
using average use min and max and avoid
using strings by using booleans and
numerical calculations
question 26 which visualization will be
used in the given scenarios here we have
three scenarios of opportunities that
you might want to visualize
and there is no perfectly exact answer
for these but there are some
visualizations that tend better for
certain types of data however there
sometimes could be
different ways to visualize it and it
doesn't mean that these are the very
best ways however if you want to take a
moment go ahead and pause the video and
go through
and figure out what your three answers
are and comment below and we can discuss
what we think the best ways are so first
we want to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of product categories and
subcategories we want to show the
duration of events or activities and we
want to show quarter wise profit growth
so to show aggregated sales totals
across a range of products subcategories
and categories you could use a tree map
the reason we bring up a tree map here
is that they are known for allowing you
to show a visualization
using hierarchies so let's take a look
at that we're going to show aggregated
sales totals across a range of product
categories and subcategories so if we
come here and make a sheet
and we want to see sales across control
click
category and subcategory and then we
click a tree map
what happens
it's showing
it based on size and color and so it
shows the size the bigger the size the
more sales and the darker the color the
more sales and the reason we choose a
tree map over just a normal heat map is
that
it makes a category here so we can
compare this box that has all the
technology in it see how all these are
technology to this box that has all of
the office supplies and you can quickly
see the technology
has more than office supplies but you
can also see that phones has more than
art and it breaks it up as a hierarchy
and breaks it up based on your sum of
sales and question two is show duration
or events a duration of events or
activities and you would use a gantt
chart gun charts are used to show
duration
and each of these lines
is a duration so it's like it's got a
start date and end date basically and it
shows you how long everything takes and
the last one is to show
profit growth and you can use a
waterfall chart and that looks like
this where you can see how the profit
changes across every period and if it's
going up or down and each one of these
show you how much up or how much down
they go
but as we said there are potentially
other answers to this question so
if you have any questions about why we
didn't say this chart or that chart go
ahead and comment below and we can start
a discussion question 27 what would you
do if some countries or provinces or any
geographical entity is missing and
displaying a null when you use map view
so when you start to map the
geographical fields that you have
sometimes tableau is unable to map them
because their locations are unknown or
ambiguous meaning a lot of states have a
city called springfield and it won't
know where to draw that city so for
example
let's look at
here so we've taken city as our detail
and it's drawn a lot of cities however
it's got a lot of unknown values here so
if this question comes up you've got to
remember these three things you can edit
locations filter the data or show data
at default position
edit locations allows you to correct the
locations
by putting in their unique names i'll
show you an example of this filter the
data means just keep them off of the
view and show data default position
means show it at zero zero on the map
so edit locations
here we can say here's all of these
cities that seem to exist
in multiple locations and we could say
well we know what state they're in as
well and that should help you answer the
question so you could choose a field
that will define the state so here we're
saying the state is from the state field
and we hit okay
and then it can draw the rest of those
cities
sometimes you want to keep them off
perhaps maybe they spelled city names
wrong and you just want to exclude those
and the last one is show data default
position
which is 0 0
28 what is a level of detail expression
a level of detail expression or an lod
expression is maybe the way they've
presented to you and lod stands for
level of detail so obviously it helps
you get to the level of detail that you
want in your visualization but it also
is used to run complex queries at the
data source level instead of all in the
tableau interface
so we're going to take a look at an
example here which is adding a dimension
to an already
calculated aggregate field in our case
we're going to exclude a dimension from
a calculated field so
here we have
a visualization that i built and right
now it's just looking at sales by
category and subcategory but say we
wanted to look at the total sales for
furniture
and not break it up by the subcategory
so if we take off subcategory
then we get the total sales for
furniture but if we want a side by side
and so that you could see the total
sales for furniture and you can see
it broken up by subcategory you can use
a level of detail calculation
this i already made the field for it
i've called it exclude subcategory so
that's right here
right now it just contains sales
but we're going to use the level of
detail calculation exclude
and we're going to tell it what to
exclude which is subcategory and then
we're going to do some
of sales so that it will sum it up for
us
and once i apply these changes it should
change it here and our labels
perfect so now we can see that it's
ignoring the fact that this is chairs
and this is table so this is bookcases
it's just doing the total for furniture
and just ignoring these because we told
it to exclude so level of detail helps
you to be able to define the level that
you want to in your visualization
regardless of what else exists on your
visualization
it also moves some of the logic from
inside of tableau to the actual database
and there are three level of detail
calculations this will be an important
thing to bring up in interviews they
might give you brownie points when you
can remember all three of the level of
detail calculations which are
we looked at exclude
we have
exclude
include
and
fixed
so include exclude are pretty easy to
remember and just always remember fixed
as well question 29 how do you calculate
daily profit measure using level of
detail here's another opportunity for
you to pause the video and take a look
at calculating a daily profit measure
using level of detail we are going to
get started
profitable level of detail so
we want to have a daily profit measure
and i already made a place for it profit
per day
and we want to look at the profit for a
day regardless
of what else is on the visualization so
we're going to use a fixed
instead of an include or an exclude
which will only take into account
whatever you put in for include or
exclude fixed will take into account
everything it will ignore everything
else on the visualization and only look
at what's in your list here so we're
going to fix it by day
and you have to put a colon
and we're going to do a sum of profit
for each of those days
and close it off so now we have our
profit per day
we'll hit ok and now we're going to make
a kpi
which for our purposes if profit for a
day is greater than 2000 then that day
is highly profitable if it's less than
zero then it's unprofitable otherwise it
is profitable so we're gonna go if
our profit per day
is greater than two thousand
then
we're gonna call it highly profitable
elsif
we're gonna do less than or equal to
zero
then
profitable
else
otherwise it is profitable
i always have to end with an end
great
okay
so now we're going to make
some visualizations and it's going to
look at it by year
now it all fits in one view we
can rotate these labels to make it
easier to see and we're going to bring
on
order id
but now it's showing like a lot of
orders and so we actually wanted to be
used as a measure and we're going to do
account distinct
great so now we can see how many orders
we're on each day
and so that's helpful for us to see how
many orders are on this day each day but
we want to see the orders on each day
that are highly profitable versus
unprofitable versus just profitable so
we're going to use
our level of detail
and break it up in a different section
so we have highly profitable profitable
and unprofitable let's also bring this
on to our color
highly profitable profitable and
profitable and now we can see
that the profitable ones are going up
unprofitable ones seem to be going down
in 2015 and that's nice but they are
going up and highly profitable is not
very many
oh in this case we did area charts
instead of just line charts to make that
change you change it from automatic to
area and that helps you see some of that
spatially as well comment below if you
were able to make this visualization on
your own
question 30 how can you schedule a
workbook in tableau after publishing it
so when you publish a workbook in
tableau if you've used an extract you're
going to need to refresh that extract so
in tableau when you create a tableau
data source and it's an extract version
of the data source it will no longer
update if the data from your database
updates so somebody's made some changes
to your database or your excel file and
you want to see that in your tableau
visualization well you're not going to
see it but you can see it if you make a
refresh so you do that on tablet server
and you can remember that you have to
get all the way to your data source so
you can go to your data sources or to
your workbooks
and then you look at the data source on
your workbook and you go actions extract
refresh and then you select schedule a
refresh so that looks like this you can
press these three dots next to it and
click refresh extracts or you can go to
actions and then here you click schedule
a refresh
instead of refresh now and then often
times in tableau you'll have several
different options you can choose daily
at 7 am or every 4 hours if an
interviewer is asking you
about how to schedule a refresh it might
be worthwhile bringing up the fact that
you only need to schedule a refresh if
you are
using an extract on your data source and
then that will help them know that you
know the difference between live and
extracts if they didn't ever ask that
question
in this tutorial we learn about what is
power bi benefits of power bi connecting
data to
it
visualizing the data here also briefly
understand on data models which help us
in connecting different data sets or
establishing relationships between them
also understanding dax expressions that
is used when you would want to work on
your data at an extensive level and then
we will have a quick demo on usage of
power bi
now what is power bi it is a business
intelligence tool to visualize your data
and share insights across your
organization
so when we talk about
bi it came into existence as a
self-service bi tool
and it does have different components
which can be used now before we get into
details of power bi let's understand
what are the different components or
what are the different ways in which you
can work on
your power bi now one of the main
challenges when it comes to
[Music]
organizations or users is that data is
scattered in different places
it might be in different formats
and anyone everyone would want to use
that data to basically perform some
calculations
create visualizations or dashboards
which could be interactive and that's
where they would want to bring all the
data in one place might be transform it
so that you can filter out and not load
huge amount of data in your system and
you can work on selective data so when
it comes to power bi it helps us in etl
it helps us in data modeling it helps in
data storage and reporting
so what are the benefits of power bi
here are some of the benefits
so extract intelligence rapidly and
accurately so that's
basically transforming your enterprise
data into rich visuals and accurate
reports for enhanced decision making now
one thing we already know
that when we talk about data data in raw
format might have a lot of hidden
information if we look at different data
sets which i'll show you in the process
it might have a lot of meaning but then
the real meaning comes out of the data
if we can create visualizations
if we can create relationships between
different data sets
and thus that can help us in
enhanced decision making
now
power bi supports advanced data services
it integrates seamlessly with advanced
cloud services like cortana to provide
results for the verbal data queries as
well
when you talk about
seamlessly integrating with existing
applications that's one more benefit of
power bi so it adopts analytics and
reporting capabilities easily to embed
interactive visuals quickly in your
applications
you can build rich personalized
dashboards so it basically provides a
unified user experience with customized
dashboard and reports that meet your
exact needs
it also has a way where you can have
secure way of publishing your reports so
you can set up automatic data refresh
and rapidly publish reports allowing
multiple users to avail the latest
information across your organization or
across your working community
so power bi can connect to different
sources we'll see that in a while
so basically you have an option which
says get data and that basically opens
up a window where you can find different
type of data sources such as excel
your csv or text json pdf
getting data from databases or directly
accessing data from databases now before
we get further
into understanding how power bi looks
like it would be a good idea to share
information in how you can set that up
on your machine so when it comes to your
power bi
and let me open up a notepad here
so for example
i bring up a notepad
let's say when you talk about your power
bi components
so you basically have
power bi desktop
and that's mainly your playground or
that's mainly used for
any kind of development activities
you have your power bi server
or you can say service so now this one
is where
you would
make reports
online
and
share
or
make them available
to different bus
now that's one more component of rbi and
then you also have your power
bi mobile which is mainly for viewing
the information i would say viewing
reports so these are the three main
components we can also look at the
licensing information of these so these
are the main so power bi desktop is
something which you can set up on your
laptop or on your machine
power bi server is where you can log in
with your user id and password and power
bi mobile is mainly to view your reports
now how do you set this up before you
can explore or start working on power bi
so here is a link
which you can basically use
so if you look into this
so this one basically says service self
service sign up for power bi it says
sign up of power bi service as an
individual normally when you would want
to
use power bi you can use a website
called http
and then you have basically
app
and
let's say
i think it's called app powerbi.com
now this is the place where you can
basically login now if you see here i
have created an account and if you look
at my account it says auatl.on
microsoft.com now how do you get this
kind of email because when you talk
about power bi it will expect you to
have a official id and it does not take
ids which are from common
domains such as google or yahoo and so
on so this particular link gives you an
idea how you can do that so basically
you have what is power bi basic
explanation on that it says signing up
for power bi service so power bi desktop
it's a totally free download and then
you have mobile apps also a totally free
download and here it says
that what kind of email addresses it
supports
and if you look into this you have to
either
sign up because that does not accept
your private email ids or you can go for
this one which says enroll us government
organization
and this is where you can basically sign
up for power bi so
it basically says try free if you go to
the website say power bi.microsoft.com
or you could go into this one which i
was saying
http
slash
app.yourpowerbi.com
and this is what you can use or as
mentioned you can go to
powerbi.microsoft.com
for example if i open this in a
different tab
it takes me to power via microsoft i can
say start free i can click on this it
says drive free but then when it asks
you to sign in this is where
some of us face problem because it does
not take your private email id now how
do you tackle that what you can do here
is
on this page which says learn about
alternate ways to sign up you can
basically open up this link and in this
link it says sign up for power bi with
the new microsoft 365 trial
account and what you can do is you can
basically
click on this link
which takes you to the office 365
and what you can do here
is you can search for something which
says say 365 e3
and here you have tried for free
so in my case it is translating okay
so here you have an option which says
try it for free click on this one
and then basically go ahead with your
signup process now once you do that you
can basically create an account or give
a email id so it asks you to give an
email id to check if you already have an
account
and once you do that it will guide you
through the process where you can create
an account like i have done
now once you have done that so for
example
we can go into
my
this page which i said http
slash app
power bi.com
now once you have created an account you
would be asked to log in now i can click
and log in here
and then basically given my password
and once i do that it takes me to the
power bi server or service now
on the top
right it might say that go for a trial
version i have already selected that and
this is a pro trial which is giving me
validity for 60 days so this is the
service which i can use now what it
means is i can be using my power bi
desktop which would be also installed so
once you
log into this page you can basically
click on apps you can basically search
for something like power bi
and that will show up in the app and you
can install and download on your machine
now once that is there you can basically
bring it up so for example in my case i
can just say power
bi desktop
and that's the app which i have
installed on my machine
and basically that comes up so that's
your power bi desktop which is coming up
and
it will still ask you to sign in so that
you can share your information
through power bi so you see here on the
top i'm already signed in
and here it also shows you some
tutorials and videos
which basically helps you in getting to
know something more or what's new so you
can always browse that
so you would have your power bi desktop
which would be set up
you would also have your power bi
service which would be running and then
basically whatever you have developed on
your power bi desktop you can share that
through the power bi service now usually
when you talk about licensing i can give
you brief insights here so you basically
have
your
power bi service as i said licensing so
you have the pro version
which is basically
uh your
9.9 dollars
per user
per month
and basically it has some kind of
limitation so it has say max 10 gigabyte
you can work on
uh some features like incremental
refresh
is not allowed you can always look onto
the microsoft website for more details
and in those kind of cases you usually
go for the premium account if you are a
extensive user and premium account
basically is conditional based so it
depends on your requirements and then
basically you pay for the service what
you use so that's mainly about your
servicing now when you talk about your
server and service as i said it is
basically making your reports online and
sharing and making them available to
different bus so that is
the highlight so when you talk about
sharing reports
that's one of the things you have
anomaly detection
that's also possible here
you can talk about automation of reports
you have
security that is you can go for role
based or
row level based kind of security
implementation and all those are some of
the features of your power bi server and
service so it is good to know and
basically have your desktop and power bi
service setup now once you have that
then you basically have your power bi
now when you talk about your power bi it
basically helps you with various things
so this is how easily you can have it
set up and then basically you can
explore this so for example as i was
saying power bi can connect to different
data sources now i do have an option
here which says get data
i can click on this and that shows me
all the different data sources i can
even click on more if i'm interested in
looking what more power bi desktop tool
helps me to do so it shows me all the
different ways in which you can get the
data you see here the servers so the
database services your folders your
different formats you can click on file
formats or databases
you can look at power platform so if
basically you are connecting to a
platform and getting some services you
can connect to the cloud that is azure
you have online services and then you
have other options so these are all the
ways in which you can get your data when
you talk about visualizations you see a
lot of
visualization options here which can be
used once your data is loaded
and i will explore and explain more
about this so you have
something called as insert
wherein you can go in for different
visuals or different types
you can also get into say transform the
data now that basically is going to pop
up and bring a power query editor now
that's where a lot of your etl works
happen so when you when you do a
transform data it opens up power query
editor
which we can use to transform the data
or change the data or modify the data as
per our requirement before
loading all of it into our power bi
so you also have option here which says
modeling wherein we can create new
tables or we can work on our data where
we can manage relationships so as of now
we don't have any data so it does not
show this one is activated but that can
be activated this is where you can view
your reports so this is in short
exploring your power bi we'll see what
are the different options which we can
use here
so
it basically supports different kind of
data so when we look at the
visualization pane that
basically allows us to create different
kind of visualizations here and we will
understand that
so
you can basically visualize on your
different data
and create different kind of charts
graphs maps
and basically derive insights from your
data now when you talk about data models
that's where you can
basically establish relationships so
when you talk about data models
it is basically used to connect multiple
data sources to build a relationship now
we might have different data sets or we
might have data coming in from different
tables where we may want to basically
get insights or get data from multiple
data sources
for our purpose now in that case data
models to help us so for example if you
have two tables let's look at the
standard tables so you have products
lookup table
and you also have the sales table now
usually what you have in any kind of
scenario is
if we basically say you have
your data tables so that's basically
where your data resides and then you
have series of your lookup tables so
usually you might have say your data
tables here
and this is what i'm talking about which
might have some data for example let's
say
sales is one of them
you might have some other data table
which might be for example let's say
budget table
or might be something else
and
these are your data tables now at the
other end you might have your lookup
tables so basically you have various
lookup tables
and these lookup tables for example
let's say this one is customer
this one is territory
let's say this is product
and let's say this one is a calendar
so these are basically my lookup tables
so we can basically as i said your data
might be coming in from different
sources let's say database or let's say
some kind of files or let's say
some kind of systems what you have
so your data might be coming in from
different places now
you might want to transform the data so
this is where i could say there is your
query editor which i was explaining
so you have your query editor which
basically allows you
to edit the data table or basically
allows you to edit the data before it is
loaded right you can hide a column you
can add a new column you can modify your
column so your query editors would be
basically used to work on
the data which goes into your data
tables now
you might have a lot of lookup tables as
i said so let's say these are my
lookup tables
and these are my data tables
so what we need is sometimes we need
information
based on our lookup tables and data
tables now that's where data modeling
comes into picture so basically if i
would want to extract information from
here so i can notice that there is a
product key here
and there is a product key here now this
is where we are already talking about
say foreign keys or we are talking about
your relationships right now when you
talk about relational databases you have
something called as foreign key
constraints which is in in power bi
terms i would say it's not exactly a
constraint but it is more of a filter
propagation instead which is used to
basically connect your different data
sources and you could have
basically
cross filter directions you can go for
single
or one to one or one to many or many to
many kind of relationships which
basically allows you to work on the data
so we will learn more about data models
when we are doing a quick demo there
where we can talk a little bit about
normalization and denormalization
the way the data exists
right and then you basically would want
to gather insights from your data so
when you talk about your
two data sources as i said so you have a
products lookup table you have a sales
table now if you would want to calculate
the total order quantity of each product
name
which is we are talking about the order
quantity as a
information here and you have product
name here now how do you get that
information what we see here is we would
want something like this or we would
want more information so how do we do
that so what we can do is
the order quantity for each product is
basically showing us the same value now
this is because the product and sales
tables are not connected and there is no
relationship between them even if you
would want to take two sources and just
get information out of them probably i
would complain that there is no
relationship established between them so
what we do is we create a data model so
what we do is we build a relationship
between both the tables using a common
key column which exists in both cases as
i said there is a product key here
there is a product key here so that
basically allows us to have a
relationship between these two now that
could be
one to one this could also be related to
other tables so it could be one too many
you could have many to one so all those
relationships are possible so product
key is basically used to create a
relationship you see the arrow mark
and then there is also the star which
can basically mean one to many now
when the product key is used to join
these two tables or form a relationship
then we can look at the product names
and the order quantities which basically
gives me a total now that's the basic
use of your data models now what about
this dax so basically data analysis
expressions now that's a
library of functions and operators that
can be combined to build formulas and
expressions and power be a desktop
usually when we work on our data sources
when we would want to connect them it
automatically shows us these data
analysis expressions however this gives
us extension it basically gives us more
power to work on our data
now sometimes instead of working on dax
or dax expressions it would be good to
go for better data modeling and have the
relationships established better and
sometimes when the relationships are
established you could use your tax which
basically gives you more power on
working on your data so your values are
calculated based on information from
each row of a table
it appends values to each row in a table
and stores them in the model
it increases the file size so that's
what happens now you can right click on
any column to add a new column and for
example in this one it shows that there
was a quantity type calculated column
which was based on the calculation what
we see here on the top in the in the
expression bar which says what kind of
calculation was performed and that
basically gives us the value for
quantity type and that is basically
added here to our existing data
so that's the
power of dax and power bi so you also
have something called as
measures so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures so
basically here if you see we are working
on aw underscore sales and then we have
selected quantities sold
and what we are looking in the report is
we can basically right click on any
table name to add a new measure here so
we have added what we call as quantity
sold
as the measure so values are calculated
based on information from any filters in
the report we will see this how this can
be done
and that basically here the measure does
not increase the file size it does not
create new data in the table themselves
in comparison to what we were seeing
earlier that is your calculated columns
so these are your type of dax functions
so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures
so you have date and time which
basically allows you to work on date and
time
data or fields you have logical
functions which allow us to create new
filters or add more filters to our data
you have text functions which basically
allows
us to say transform the data into a
lower case or an upper case or basically
get the length of a string or
concatenate two fields
or basically
do a filtering based on some criterias
or replacing some content you also have
statistical functions which can be used
you have information functions which can
be used so these are different types of
dax functions
which we can use in power bi
so we will learn more on power bi
through a quick demo where we can use
some data sets and those data sets could
be found on internet
although i can also upload that on a
github link and you will have access to
those data sets
so let's learn about power bi through a
quick demo
by uploading some data sets and playing
with those data sets
let's
look at a sample data set and let's
upload it
and as i explained while uploading let's
also transform the data so that we can
have selective
fields so selected data loaded here
instead of loading the complete data set
and then let's see how we can visualize
this or how we can use the information
in this data set now what we can do here
is we can click on get data and then we
can choose one of the data formats which
we would be
looking for so for example i can go for
excel
and basically
click on this now here are some of my
data sets so let's look into
the folder here
and
these data sets are also available on my
github link which i'll share with you
later so here we have something called a
super store let's click on this and here
i already have a data set which is
global super store or i also have
selective data so let's
select this one
click on open
now
that's basically connecting to my data
source and that will show me what does
that excel sheet have so it has
different tabs
which is orders people and returns so
let's select orders
and that basically gives me a preview of
the data which i have and if you scroll
all the way to right it shows me city
state
and then country and if you see here we
do see information of all the countries
now this can be huge amount of data
which may which we would want look into
but say for example my use case is that
i'm interested in looking for the data
for united states and
as a country and all it states so we
will do that when we do a transform
now we can also select the returns tab
and that shows me
these three fields however the first row
should have been the heading of this
particular data set and we will
transform that now i can go ahead and
click on load but that will load all the
data so instead of that let's go for
transforming so let's click on transform
data now once you do that it brings you
your toolkit that brings you your power
query editor which allows you to
transform your data so for example we
have
our data from returns tab or returns
data source as you see here so we see
column 1 column 2 and column 3 and that
also shows the type of
the data here
it also gives me this quick small option
here let's select this and then i can
say use first row as header now there
are various other options which you can
do you can add a custom column you can
add column with examples you can keep
the top rows
you can remove the top rows you can keep
errors keep duplicates so there are
different ways and you can also do a
merge query or append query so as of now
let's just say use first row as headers
and that basically shows that now my
first row has become the header you also
see
in the applied steps it basically tells
me
if i have changed the type of the data
if i have made any other changes those
steps will get added here
so it basically shows me the name as it
returns it shows me applied steps where
i have changed the type
and now i basically have this
information now this is something where
you can change the type or you can
basically set it to a particular format
however we are not doing anything of
that sort right now
so we can do that for any of these
columns so this looks good
when it comes to orders let's click on
this and as i said i would be interested
in selecting for country as united
states only and let me just work on that
data however we can work on all the data
so let me scroll all the way to right
and here i have the country now there
are these filters which we can use
so basically i can click on this and
that shows me all the countries are
selected now there is also something
called as text filters which we will see
how we can use to select particular data
i basically have
other ways of filtering the data so for
example now i will just uncheck the
select all and what i would be
interested is in united states so let's
type it here that shows me has an option
here
select this
and then basically say okay
so that should basically now filter out
and it shows me the data is united
states
only and then you have different states
and rest of the data remains so if you
look at the applied steps it tells me
that there are filtered rows
now we have done the basic
transformation for this data set
on these two data sources that is orders
and returns so here you have an option
which says close and apply so close the
query editor window and apply any
pending changes you can click on this
and it says apply
so for example i can just say apply for
now and that should basically apply the
changes
which i have performed
using my query editor that is i have
transformed the data so that i can have
selective
data uploaded in my power bi now it's
doing that it shows me it is working on
both of these data sources that is
orders and returns so that's done and
now basically if there are any other
pending changes we can
just do a close and apply
so that basically has closed and now you
would see the data appearing here
so i have uploaded the data
as per
my preferences now if you click on
the data tab here
so it basically shows you your data
fields it might take some time to
populate but if you see in the country
field now
if even if i click on the filter it just
shows me united states now that's what
we wanted so we have already uploaded
this data in orders you can always
expand the
option here which shows me all the
fields which are there in this might be
this is an aggregation might be that's
an ordered date so this is again some
kind of aggregation we can change the
data types so we are looking at all the
fields in my orders table or basically
coming from the orders data source i
also have returns which shows me three
fields and that shows me the data which
is returned order id and region so the
column names are applied correctly as we
want and that basically looks fine now
we can also look at
your
model so when you click on model it
shows me these two however there is no
as of now relationship established
between them so it says
under properties select one or more
model objects to set their properties so
right now these are not related there is
no relationship established between them
so if i would want some data which
relates to orders and returns
then that would fail because it would
say there is no relationship now i can
go to the first option which says report
and we have not created any report here
although we can create a simple report
we can look at the data so we have our
orders field now we can basically pull
out some information from here we can
choose what kind of report we may want
to create so for example let's go for
the table option from visualizations you
have various options here which we can
use
this is where you can do a formatting
this is where you can select the fields
this is where you can search and filter
out the data you can also add data
fields here so first let's click on
table
and that basically gives me a table now
this table
as of now does not have anything so you
can use the filter and slices
option here which will affect the
visualization or basically what you can
do is now since we have
orders here so this is my orders and i
would like to work on this so let's say
for example country
is i can select country as a field and
if you say it shows me country is all as
of now and it says the value is united
states what i can also do is i'm
interested in the states
so i have state now i can basically drag
and drop it here and then the state gets
added here so i can basically say select
all
and that should basically take care of
my
state field being added here
so state is all country is all
now
we can basically look at something else
so might be let's choose sales
and i can just drag and drop sales here
so that basically says if you would want
to have any kind of advanced filtering
which says filter type so go for
advanced filtering is less than or equal
or you can also go for advanced filters
so
that's fine as of now so we have added
some fields here
and that's basically
my data here
so
let's go for
filters here
which basically should select all my
fields
now if you see the visualization shows
my country
sales and state which we had either by
selecting the fields and dropping
them here or you can in this section
where it says field so you can for
example let me show it again so i can
just delete this
i can click on the table option
i can just drag it here
i can basically make it bigger and i
need to add data to this one so it says
add data fields here so now let's say
country is what we are interested in we
are also interested in states
so let's drop that here and let's say
sales so this is also what i'm
interested so i'm looking at one
specific country i'm looking at sales
per state and when we look at
sales it basically tells me that this is
summation so you will basically get
the total sales which have happened now
we are looking at this data here we can
always go to formatting we can click on
grid we can basically increase the font
here we can change the grid color
so for example let's make it for example
blue
so i can just select this
and it should basically
allow me to have the grid color as blue
now i can go in for the grid thickness i
can go for row padding outline color
so we can basically make it a little bit
more readable
and then we can basically increase the
font size here
to look at the information
and you have other options here so what
would you want to do with column headers
so i can basically have the font color
background color is fine
do you want to have an outline
do you want to have a change in font
what is the text size might be we can
make the heading a little bigger
and then basically you also have the
field formatting so all those could be
done you could go for background and all
these things can be done in formatting
so now we already have our data here and
this
basically looks good and this is
basically
one of my visuals
which i have here
and this has given me some information
for sales and basically i can scroll
this i can
also make it bigger
so i could select a particular field if
i'm more interested in looking at the
information for a particular state now i
can add more fields to this
so this is
my
one of the reports which i have created
now
what
i can do with this report is i can
basically have more data fields i can
add filters to this
i can basically look into all the data
here by just clicking somewhere in the
grid but somewhere outside if you select
a particular row then that data shows up
here you have an option of focus mode
which you can go for you can look at the
other options which says export data now
if this is the data which you are
interested in
you can export it you can always to
show as a table if you are interested in
you can do a sort by country sales or
state so for example let's do a sorting
by state
and that basically gives me the data
which has been sorted by state
information
now we could obviously have
the information here so i can then
change the order so it shows me
alphabetically this is the information
which i have so i've created a simple
visualization
using the
data which i have and what i can do is i
can click on save so that basically asks
me to save this as a power bi file which
has an extension of pbi x and i can
basically call it my report so let's say
first
report
and here i can say country
or i can say
state
wise
sales
in
usa
let's say
usa
and that basically is my first report
now
once you have saved this report you can
always look on your machine for example
if i go in here
and if i go into this folder might be i
should look on desktop
and
this is where i should have saved it so
it shows me first report statewide that
will open up in power bi and we have
created a simple report which we have
basically used by taking our data now i
can also do is i can publish this if i
would want to
share this information so
publish this report online in power bi
service
you can basically select
your report what we have here
and i clicked on publish so it says
what's the destination so you can have
different workspaces i will choose the
default that's my workspace i can click
on select now it says publishing first
report statewide sales in usa to power
bi you can create a portrait view of
your report and you can do all that
stuff so let it publish and then we can
basically look into our power bi server
that's a service where the information
is already shared
or published i would say which can then
be shared with different resources so we
can come here
and basically i can look into the power
bi
and this is where i will be able to look
into my workspaces and let's look in my
workspace so it says this is the place
where i had initially downloaded power
bi data set it says your data set is
ready let power bi help you explore your
data right so you can always do this you
can click on view data set
which basically allows you to
bring out your workspace and first
report state wise sales now that's the
report which we have published so let's
first check in our desktop if that's
done so it says
success open first report in power bi
now i can click on this one straight
away and that takes me to my service
now once it takes me to the service it
shows me
the report which we created
which we published and it basically has
the option where i can save it
as
a
a different copy or give a different
name i can embed this in
a website or a portal i can publish to
web
embed this report for public access by
anyone on the internet we can do that we
can export it to powerpoint so we can do
all these options you also have an
option of view where you can change the
view you can basically also edit report
here so you can do that if you are
interested in something specific
you can do a sharing to teams so if you
have your teams or groups set up you can
share it with them
you have an option of common panes you
can basically
view usage metrics report now that can
be sometimes helpful
you can basically go ahead and go
and subscribe a particular report so if
there are new changes made you will be
the one who will be informed you can
click on share now if i click on share
here from my service it says only users
with power bi pro will have access to
the support recipients will have the
same access as you unless row level
security on the data set further
restricts them so i can grant access and
this is where i will have to give the
email ids of the people
with a message
that i would want to have them
look at this report
right you can also allow recipients to
build new content using the underlying
data sets
and you can send an email notification
to the user so as of now i don't have
any other groups so i'll not be sharing
it but i have created a simple report
now let's also look at edit report let's
just to see what it helps us and when
you click on edit report it basically
brings up this one which says your file
view
it gives you the filters it basically
allows you to add data fields to this so
it is basically giving access to these
data sets
which were in my desktop
it is basically allowing you to give or
create different visualizations
now here we have the data which we are
looking at and if say for example
somebody is interested in filtering the
data so you could do that so you could
click on filter here and that basically
applies this is the filter we have now
country is fine sales
might be i can click on sales and i
would say okay let's look at
sales which is more than a particular
amount so we can say is
greater than
and might be i can give a number here so
i can say 30 000
and basically
i can say apply filter
so right now i'm liking filter and i
would look at the values
which also shows me the total value is
changed so
you have not only created a report you
have published it and now
from the service you can edit it so i'm
looking at particular data here and then
basically i can click on file and i can
save it or i can say save a copy of the
report and let's say
i will call it
the same name so i'll say first
report underscore
state wise
sales
and i will say modified
so let's do a save
and the report has been saved
so now you're looking at the data here
so
that is basically giving you information
so when i click on my
workspace here
i can click on reports and that does
show me my previous report it shows me
the modified report it gives me an
option of looking at the usage metrics
report so say for example you want to
click on this one and it will basically
give you the usage metrics so let's
click on this one
and
that basically shows me the report usage
metrics which is generated so views per
day unique viewers per day
you would want to look at the different
platforms who was using it views by user
and this can be sometimes useful if we
would want to look into this one now i
can go back to my workspace i can click
on reports
and that basically
took me to usage metrics i could be
sharing it
i can analyze in excel
i can look for quick insights based on
this data what we have
you can basically look at the related
information you can also look at the
settings of this one
and basically this is how you have your
data report here now that also shows me
the data sets option so which basically
gives me
the data sets which can be used to
create further reports and we have our
data here
so
for example if i click on create report
it basically gives me these data sets
and we can continue working on this so
this is how i have
a simple report created without
basically working on two different data
sources but i have selected some data
here
and then i can basically add details to
this so for example now if we look at
orders and say for example this is the
data i have
and say you would want to add some
fields so let's go to returns and say
for example i would be interested in
looking at
the the products so might be what i
should do is i should replace the report
here instead of country it would be
interesting to look at
the product
which we have or basically customer id
so we can look at customer id we can
look at the order id which would be
interesting to see if there is a
particular order
what was the sales which was generated
and if there were any returns which were
happening on that so for example here
when i have these let me cut out country
as a field and i will basically take
order id and place it here
so now if you see my data has been
easily modified
so i have my order id i have sales and i
have
statewide information so
you have basically all the information
but this is now order id state and so on
now what if i would want to
also see
based on the order id if i say i would
want the returned field
so for example i would want to take this
one and let's drag and drop it here
now that says cannot display the visual
now why is that so if you click on see
details that says cannot determine
relationships between the fields so it
cannot display the data because power bi
cannot determine the relationship
between two or more fields
and how do we fix that so for example if
i click on fix this now it says
there is a missing relationship between
these fields use auto detect to search
for relationships or create them
manually now i can click on auto detect
which will try to search for fields
which exist in both the data sets or
basically i can create relationships so
let's click on create relationships and
that basically takes me to this page
which says there are no relationships
defined
from table to table and so on
so
i can click on new
now here it says select the tables and
the columns that are related now i can
say orders now those are my fields where
you have order ids and it automatically
shows that returns also has an order id
field although all the values might not
be same but this is how you can create a
relationship and it says the cardinality
says many to one so you can have
basically many to one relationship you
are saying cross filter direction is
single
so make this relationship active and it
has already helped us basically
identifying the field so i can say okay
so it says
now these two tables should be related
or should be connected based on order id
so
here we have this and let's basically
say close
now
once that is done
if you see
i have order id i have returned
i have sales column and i have state and
if you see in returned i do have a value
of yes
which shows
this particular order id
had generated some sales and it was for
state alabama and it was returned
and the value is yes so if you scroll
down you basically see all the values
now we can add different filters where
we can say i would want only yes and no
now this is again an interesting report
so let's go in also into the formatting
and what we can do is we can look at
say the grid option if we would want to
basically say vertical grid and let's
say
on
and it says vertical grid color so let's
select this might be i can try doing a
black here it puts it in the right nice
table format and that basically looks
good so you have
sales
returned and so on and this is basically
the order which i am seeing here so for
example if i would want to
change the order and if i am saying okay
i would like to look at sales and
returned and so on so we can be doing
that we can come here and say for
example i have sales and returned let's
try
moving the sales column over here
might be state is
an information which we would want in
the beginning so let me also
move the states all the way here so it
gives me state it gives me the order id
sales and if
there was
a return which was happening on that
particular product so easily i've
modified my report now what i can do is
i can just save it
and i can do the same thing so i can
publish it i can basically continue
using it or i can work on a new report
so let's continue learning and
now here we will also see
how you can load some data and perform
some transformations and basically get
multiple results or multiple tables or
multiple data sets which can be then
further used for reporting so power bi
does give you a lot of options now here
you have an option as we saw earlier
that is get data or what you can do is
you have an option where you can
create new data also it says enter data
now this is something which can be
easily used if you have
relatively
less number of fields so you can
basically add
more
columns here and you can basically add
values so for example if i would just
call it something like
scientist id
okay and then i can say scientist name
and then basically i can say
uh
domain
[Music]
and then i can say for example let's say
year of joining and
and i can keep adding the number of
columns here i can delete the columns
right and i can give this and i can say
country
so
that's it and now we have created these
five
countries sorry five columns which we
have given some names and we can start
entering some values so
i can basically say let this scientist
id be
22 3 4
i can give some name so let's give peter
let's say domain and i can say
biotechnology
i can give year of joining 2011 and i
can say germany as the country
and i really don't want this particular
column so i can go ahead and delete this
now i can come here
and then i can give something else so i
can say this is scientist id
i can give john
let's say
the scientist is mainly working in
physics
and then i can say 2018 and let's say
france
and go back here and let's say
four five six seven and let's say
marie
and let's say
she does her research in
uh molecules and let's call it 2001
and let's say
italy
okay and you can continue adding data in
this way now you can
say if the data is already here so i can
say for example no i do not want
this particular row
i do not want this particular row
so
you can basically keep adding values
here now you can say edit
so
here we have to give some name so let's
say
scientists
okay
and then
if you choose edit
it basically brings up your power bi
editor which allows you to work on these
fields if you would want to make some
changes now we can make some changes
here we can see
what are the number of rows we can
basically perform any kind of
transactions here so this one basically
tells me what is the data type so here
we see scientist id and this clearly
tells me this is an integer however we
will not want to do any kind of
computations here so
we can as well change this so i can just
do a right click and i can work on this
particular column what i can also do is
i can just click on this
and this tells me that you would want to
change it to
date time or you want to change it to
some number so i can just say string
because we are not going to perform any
computation here so on the id column so
let's say
text
and i'm changing it so it says replace
current add a new step so selected
column has an existing type conversion
would you like to replace the existing
conversion or preserve the existing so i
will say replace current and now the
data type has been changed it is
of a string and if you see this step has
got added here so it says that
the change type
is the kind of transformation we did
here so that's fine now what we can also
do is we have the scientist name but we
don't like the column name here so it
would be good to change this
so there is something called as
remove or remove columns and so on so
when you do a right click it gives you a
lot of options in applying filters or
doing some transformation if i just
click on this one so what i can do is i
can look at the date time
and
let's go here so we have
an option which says do you want to
change the type now we could have done
that here or like i said you could
choose the time and do it you can just
say transform and how do you want to
change it so do you want to change it to
uppercase well you can do that and
changes all the values of this one
what i can do is i can again do a right
click and i can choose
basically if you would want to clean up
the data or if you would want to convert
to lowercase you want to capitalize each
word
so let's choose that and if you see here
the steps are getting added now to undo
any particular step if i just
cancel this then i'm back to this if i
cancel this i'm back to my original form
so you can anytime undo your changes
and you can basically work on this
so
we are working on this particular column
now there are various other options that
you can look at so for example these are
this is some of my data but it does not
have much information it would be good
to load
some bigger data set and then use these
transformations or basically
working on changing the data types as i
mentioned
or if you would want to do a filtering
and remove certain fields and only
select particular fields if that's what
you're interested
doing a right click where i want to
create a copy of this and then basically
i can
use that particular copy
now what i can also do is
i can add column from examples i can
duplicate column and then i can
make some changes to that so this is my
duplicate column and say for example you
would want
this one to be changed so
we can
say remove duplicates we can basically
if you are doing some kind of change you
want to change the format here you can
do that you can use for other things
like filling up and all that now i can
just call it rename and let's say
um
alias scientist name right and i can
continue adding columns or i can do some
transformations and once you have done
with these transactions now this one if
you see it shows as integer but is it an
integer no this is an date format so i
can go for modeling and change the
formats what i can also do is i can
select this and it says it's not a
decimal it's not a fixed decimal it is
date time it is date
it is date time and time zone
right and you can select any one of
these so for example let's make it date
which
makes it more meaningful but then what
happens is when you do this it is going
for the default dates or the older dates
so i don't like that
so what we will have to do is we will
have to
basically transform this and
here we have transform you have change
type
so you have date and time you have date
you have time so let's choose date and
time and if you see here it gives me
some default timing based on these
values which we do not like so again
filter it out but what we can do is we
can just
make sure that this is
changed or you want to make it a string
because we are not going to do any
computation here so i can keep it as
date but then if i have more fields like
month and days and so on
then you can do that so here it also has
the option so when you have selected
this you have an option called transform
and transpose sorry transform also has
various options which allow you to work
on these do you want to do some
scientific calculations do you want to
work on
the date field so as of now it is just
integer so we can use one of these we
can do a group by but
obviously we don't have much data here
so as of now let us retain this i can
just change this to text and that's okay
because we are going to look at this
later we can add more data and work on
it so as of now once we have done all
these changes you can go back to
say home and here you have close and
apply and i can basically say close and
apply so the changes will be
applied and then my new table which we
just created by entering some random
data
performing some basic transformations
will be available so if you look into
this one
so that's where my data is it shows me
the columns but there is no aggregated
column as such here you don't see any
summation mark you just see the field
names or the column names you see the
values now obviously if you go into
modeling
there is no
or there is no existence of a different
table which you can join these tables or
you can perform some transactions
come back to the data set so this looks
good and we have it here now obviously
we have not created any visualization
based on this which we can and we can
continue working on it so here this is
my data set
which is a small table where we have
created some data and we can use it
anytime
now let's work on a bigger data set and
see what kind of transformations we can
do
we can then also see on modeling or
basically using some smarter ways of
working with the data
so what we would want to do is we would
want to
load some data here
so let's go into
sorry let's go into home let's go to get
data
let's use our old store data and i'm
going to take the global super store
which is huge data set with all the
countries and the products and the sales
which have happened
and we can take this data but before
loading it as i suggested earlier we
should basically transform the data we
should basically transform the data so
that you don't end up loading everything
and you don't work on all the data i
mean unless you really want to
so here i will this excel sheet which i
am talking about has two different tabs
we have used it before so let's use
orders let's use
returns
and that basically shows me the data
what we have so i can do a load but
that's not what we would want to do so
you can do a load and you can get all
the data but let's go to transform
make some basic transformations before
we load the data so our power
bi editor allows us to work on this now
here we have
it says this preview may be up to nine
days old
so i can do a refresh i can select this
and i say first thing is use first row
as header because that's what i want
so it is basically
setting the first row as header which
looks good
and we have some order ids
we have the
returned if the product was returned so
let's look at the filter here so it just
has
yes values
which we are looking at so
it says list may be incomplete let's say
load more
and let's see what are the filters here
so either there might be a product which
is returned or it might be blank field
so that is chosen so that's fine we have
order id we have region which is
basically showing me different regions
here
let's look at orders
and orders
is again having your row id order id
order date
ship date ship mode so you have quite a
large amount of data here for your
different countries now in earlier
example i chose united states and then i
was only focusing on the states and city
in united states so we can do that now
i can basically work on refresh so
whatever preview was stored in the
memory we are just refreshing it now
here we have this
row id and if you see the row id is an
integer obviously we will not be
performing any kind of computation here
so here
you don't have any row id but here we
have row id so let's make it
uh from integer let's make it string
and
i'll say replace current so that's that
looks fine it's a row id which we will
use to search but we are not going to
perform any computations unless you want
to find on
an average on row id or anything else
now you have order ids so
what we can do is we can
filter some values
we can rename the field as we desired
right so for example let's go in here
and what we can do is let's go into
a customer id ship
okay
and here you have say state you have
region
okay now at any point of time if i would
want to filter out the values the easier
option is
that you can select on this one and here
you can do some text filtering
okay or you can basically select the
values from here so for example
if i say let's get rid of select all
what we will be interested in
say united states and uk that's the data
we want and then
i can basically say okay
so
it is basically going to filter out the
data which is for united states and uk
as of now now what we can also do is how
about doing some more filtering before
we basically work on this so let's go in
here and we are looking at united states
and uk related data
and let's look at
it is sometimes good that you can
basically
uh work on the data here so for example
i go into orders now what i would want
to do is i would want to look at
the fields
okay
and we want to we have not yet loaded
the data so if you look in the
background i just have my scientists
because we have not applied these
changes we have not loaded we are still
in the
transformation stage right now what we
can do is let's go for
so we can do
segment and all these kind of fields
can be used for grouping the data so we
will see that whenever you have a data
set you would already know there are
certain fields which have repeated
values which can be used to group the
data
and we can do that we can
change
any kind of values which are not
going to be computed on so for example i
have postal code i can
use this but again we are not going to
find a postal code which is greater than
something right so integer is not the
valid type let's change it to text
okay and
if for example
i would want to
look at this so i have done some
changes here
okay and this shows me null so for
example let me just reword this back
and let's make it
a whole number
okay so there are certain
columns or rows which do not have some
values and we can basically get rid of
those values so as of now we can do a
filtering here
so let's keep the postal code as integer
or let's
change it to text do a replace
content
and now what we will do is we'll scroll
all the way right
might be i'm interested in
technology category so that's what i'm
interested in so what i can do is here i
can do some filtering
so i can basically choose
technology now the easier way would be
since these are categories and there are
only three categories we really don't
want to go and apply text filters here
but if you had something like an office
supply
and
office inventory
then you could have done some text
filter so let's not do some text
filtering here what we can do is i would
be interested in technology
so that's the field i'm interested in so
now you are only having data which is
related to technology
okay and you have some product names so
this is where we want to do some kind of
filtering
so
we can rename the field we can select
some fields so let's for example let's
go for
[Music]
any of the field which i think might
have more entries here so for example
let's go for
canon wireless or canon image right so
let's go for product names
and i will say let's
go here
now i could have done a transformation
but that's not what we want we want to
do some filtering so let's go to text
filter
and here
i can say begins with
i can say ends with i can say contains
so let's go for contains and it says
enter a value here so
you would want to keep the rows where
the product name contains something and
it gives you some suggestion
right so where you are seeing in some
values here so for example if i would
have selected this then it applies the
complete thing but that's not what i
want so i will
get rid of all this and i will say it
contains canon now i can go for advanced
filtering also
okay
wherein you can select advanced and then
you can give
different columns
and
what do they contain
what kind of values you're looking for
so you can do that but we will not go
for advanced in one step let's go for
basic and let's say okay
and now
i should get all the products which are
canon
and you have different products so this
is one kind of filtering i've done it
tells me what is the category of this it
is machines it is copiers
it is obviously belonging to the
technology category we are looking at
the market which is for this particular
data when you look at the country we are
still focusing on united states and
united kingdom that kind of data right
so we have filtered the data we have
done some
selection based on the data here and
what i can do is i can then
basically
rename a particular field
so i can do that i can say i'm
interested in
sales
which is the data here
we can
basically look into the quantity so
sales is something which we are
interested in but might be we are
interested in sales which are
more than a particular value i'm not
interested in lower amount of sales i
would want to look into united states in
uk data but i am interested in sales or
i am looking at
if the discount percentage was something
or if the profit was
more right so we can apply different
kind of values here but
what we can do is with these changes
because you don't want to transform and
make changes all here
you want to make the changes once the
data set is uploaded so we have selected
some data
we have create done some transformations
we can basically
break a particular column into multiple
columns if that's what we want if we see
that we will do an aggregation based on
here
or we will do a aggregation based on the
country or year and order id right so we
can break this data into multiple
columns so we can do that but for now
let's do a close and apply
and
let's apply this so that's going to
apply all these changes it's going to
load my data but remember now we are
having selective or selected data which
gets loaded
so that should get be available here so
it takes time sometimes
so you have to wait
and then you can go ahead and check here
so for example now i'm looking in tables
let's basically minimize this let's go
for orders and this is the data i have
which obviously row id if you see
so you have all the row ids and again
again you can do filtering here but this
is where you have already loaded the
data the data is available
and then you can start working on the
columns here
so we have this
if you closely see we see this summation
mark and this basically means that
these are my aggregated columns or these
values are measures which can be used
for calculations so we can see that we
can create our own aggregations so we
can do that we can rename the field as
we have seen
we can filter out the data so we have
all the fields showing up from orders
and let's also look at the returns
which basically has the columns the
order id and your region
so
it basically shows the region here where
was the
product returned from and we have this
information so what we are doing is we
when we were doing a text filter in the
previous example
remember it was case sensitive
okay and you have to take care of when
you're doing a text filter you have to
give a field which exactly matches as it
exists in the content now
okay this is the data we have and let's
look at the order column right now what
we can do is we can do some quick
transformations here and we can
basically look for
more data here so
let's say we have
some filtering to be done now
i can do a filtering based on my
uh
products
so we had all these products but now
let's do a filtering on product and then
products you have copiers you have
machines
so you have
mainly two categories right and when you
look at machines it basically talks
about your pc
uh
something so let's look for machines and
here
we have
basically the copier fields which are
more
so i can basically
go for filtering here
and that's the data we have so we don't
want to really unselect any of these
here but what i'm doing is i'm saying
text filter and let's go into this one
now
and let's say contains
okay so i'm saying contains and then i
can basically say
let's say copier
now that's what i'm interested in
and
show rows where product name contains
copier okay now you can give a and
condition here
so
if you would want a specific copier if
you are interested in okay let's also
say
uh contains and let's go for laser also
laser
and let's say okay
so you see the data gets filtered out
here and
we have the sales which we are seeing
here so let's go to sales and we will be
interested in anything above
500 so let's go to sales
let's go for number filters let's say
greater than
and i will say for example 500 oh sorry
500
okay
and
let's say okay
so that basically filters out the data
and then
i am also interested in quantity where i
would want
the quantity to be
more than
1 or more than 2 so for example so let's
go in
here
and you can basically choose what is the
filter you want so you can apply any
number of filters now you have the
filtering here you can always click on
the filter and if you want you can just
do a clear filter and the filtering will
be gone so you have all the data right
and
this is
the particular data we have and here i
have say for example
product name now i can keep the filter
because i'm interested only in these
values or
i can filter out so this tells me that
when we did it and
it is basically going for laser and
copier right so
let's say for example clear all filters
the thing is gone what we can do is
let's go here
go for text filters say contains and
here i will say
it can be a copy here okay or
so last time we did a and and i'll do it
contains laser
so
let's choose this that gives me more
entries so either the product name has
copier or it has laser
it has the quantity it has the product
name
and we have all this detail here now
what we can also do is we can do some
transformation on the product id so for
example you have product id or order id
so order id shows up as
looks like the country name
the year and then the order id so we can
basically
split it up so i can select this and
here
i have option of
let's go to home so when you have you
have selected this column so you have an
option of transform data here so use the
power query editor to connect prepare
and transform the data so if you really
want to transform the data here if i
basically select this
if i
just where i click here
now here it just tells me do you want a
new column do you want to create a copy
of this column
okay you want to create copy table so
this is your transformed data what you
have and for example let's create a copy
table
and let's come in here
so
you should be able to see your
copy table now so let's go in
and select this one
and what you need to do here is creating
a copy of this or copy table would not
be the right option what we can do is we
can work on
transforming this rather than doing it
from here so you have this option of
adding a new column going for a new
measure
renaming it right so that's
okay but what we can do is select this
particular column let's do a home
and first thing is let's go to transform
so i want to transform the data now
let's select this one
and it brings up your power editor again
here we were interested in orders so we
are looking at
our data here
now if you see my country's united
states and uk so you can confirm that if
you look at category it is technology
product name has copier and laser as we
selected so those things are retained so
you have not lost any changes as of now
so this order id column what we have now
as i said you can be doing a filtering
okay you can select this particular
column and then you have other things
which can be used to transform here like
you want to change the data type you
want to use first row as header you want
to replace some values
okay you want to run some merge queries
you want to do some analytics so all
these options are here now what we can
do is while this column is selected i
can do a right click now there is an
option called transform which is
basically going to help me in changing
the data here okay now i can basically
duplicate the column so i really don't
want to work on this column itself but
it would be good to have
a duplicate column on which we can work
on so i can do a split column here if i
would want to but let's create a
duplicate column so let's say duplicate
column
now that gives me a duplicate column so
we can rename it later so now i will not
work on my original column but i'll work
on a duplicate column and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to
basically transform or split this so
again where i click
now you have a split by so we can say
split by by delimiter or by number or by
characters or by position so by
lowercase and uppercase so you can do
all of this so let's go for by delimiter
now if you see
it basically identifies the delimiter
which is hyphen or dash now you can go
for split at left most
identify right sorry left most delimiter
right most each occurrence of delimiter
and that's what we want to do you can
look into advanced options where it says
split into columns
so do you want to split that into
columns do you want to split that into
rows because that's more or less like
doing a group by and you can say number
of columns to split into
so we have here one two three four
values so that looks good to me
and
let's do
say for example if i choose 3
so i can choose 3 and then split using
special characters so you could do that
so let's for example let's say okay
and let's look at the data how it looks
like we can anytime delete the data we
can keep it the way we want right so
what we did was we created a copy of the
column
then we did a split
and
what we have seen is we just have three
columns now if you see the fourth bit is
gone fourth bit doesn't show up right
because i just did a three
as the
resulting column so i have the order id
okay and we can check if there is
already an order id column so we have
order id but that has the complete order
id year and the
relatively product id so you can see the
customer id you can look at this one so
it basically has
your order id and then let's look at
the fields here
so we have
the product id which says t e c m a i'm
looking at the first one 3 7 0 0
and
that has in no relation to the order id
right so we can make sure that there is
nothing which is
conflicting with our entries now once
that is done so we have order id which
can be used to categorize the data
you have order id which is basically the
year
okay and you have order id
which is
basically having some more value now i
can keep this data as i want so i can
basically click on this i can go for
renaming and i can say let's say let's
call it
order
id
and let's say
ids so let us
in case there is
a particular column and you would want
to look at
so
just give the name correctly now order
ids is fined
so here we will also rename this one so
let's call it
order
year
and that's going to be order here so we
can again change this to string
okay and here you have the order id so
let's rename this one
and i have my
let's call
order
number
right
so we have we are seeing all the steps
which we have added here we just split
the data based on the delimiter and we
have
now three new columns which have got
added to our existing data which was
already filtered
and we have done some
splitting up of data by creating a
duplicate and then renaming it right so
if you
go and look at your transformations now
if i would have done a split here
straight away then my original column
would be gone but probably we want the
original column because sometimes you
may want to search order id with a
consolidated information sometimes you
may want to segregate it based on
year right now we have the year field or
order date field here you have the ship
date right but then might be you want to
just aggregate based on year you don't
want to really spend time in aggregating
or extracting the month and day and so
on so my these three columns can be
useful now what i can also do is i can
merge the columns if i want so we have
split the columns but what i can do is i
can say select
select
select
so using your control and now do a right
click so you should have an option
called merge columns right now this is
something which is
we would want to merge
so let's say merge columns and let's say
do you want to keep a separator so yes i
want to keep a separator but might be
this time i will give my separator is a
colon
and then what is the merge column name
you want to create so let's call it
something like um
order
okay
uh
year
and then let's call it
num
right so sometimes renaming the fields
to a name which makes more sense or
based on your naming convention is good
so let's do a merge
and
now what i have done is i have done
merging of those columns
so
i split the data i merge the columns and
now if you see my
the columns which i had created those
columns are gone because you did a merge
you did a merge and now you have the
fields which are either
[Music]
earlier you had
something which is
separated by
a
hyphen and here you have
something which is separated by colon
right now anytime if you want you can
unmerge this by removing this step right
and you can get rid of this merged
column so if for example i would do that
so
i have my data back
right i have my data back so what we
could have done is we can select this
okay and then what we can do is like
what we did earlier so you can
basically
go for
removing the columns
okay you can do a merge column
okay
you can select one by one and create
duplicate of those and then you can
merge them right so all the possible
options are there so you can the best
option would be to create a duplicate of
these columns and then basically merge
them as per your convenience so might be
you can say order id is an order number
is the pairing what you want here is
something which you don't want right
because we already have the date field
so i can basically say remove
and this one is gone now i will select
this and this
and let's go for merge columns and
i want to give a separator which is
might be without the ear and you have
space
or you can go for custom like earlier we
had
give a
symbol
and then what do you want to call it so
let's say order
specs
okay
right so this makes more meaning because
we already have the date field so why do
i want the ear into my order id so i can
always be doing a segregation now based
on order specs
right now this is some simple
transformations what we are doing here
we are seeing the
data which we have
okay now what i can do is i can
basically first apply these changes
so that all my changes what i have done
are applied
right now once these changes are done we
can basically go ahead and
save this file
so i can just say save i can go for save
as i have different other options so if
you would want to
perform keep performing your
transformation then you can just do this
you can add a column you can view the
data so for now our transformations are
good enough and what we can do is we can
basically
go back to home we can do a close and
apply and we will be back to
our data set which has been modified so
we can see if the data what we have has
been transformed
so we have order specs here that's good
we did not do any filtering or
we have the filter left here which
basically tells me that there are these
different fields we have not removed
them but what we are doing is we are
just applying a filter to choose copiers
and laser printers
so that's what we have here
and this is good enough now what i can
do is once this is done
i can basically save it
so i would want to call it some kind of
report if you would want to create okay
so let's call it
as
[Music]
let's say second
report
and here i will say
country
and
technology
specific
info
let's save it
and
now basically i have saved my data
so what you can do is you can go for
creating other report or basically
having this information published if
that's what you want to do if you want
to go for visualization because right
now what we are seeing is we have lot of
data here we have lot of data here it
shows me there are these
tables or data sets which we have worked
on that shows me
here in the models but there is no
relationship with them
if you go into visualization then you
don't have
any option or you have not created any
visualizations based on this data but if
you go here
now based on the data what we
transformed if you see
we have order specs
right now that's what we chose
we basically have other fields so you
have ship date you have aggregated
columns which can be used for
visualizing and we can work on this
so i can come back here and what i would
be interested in
is this data set is fine but i want to
do some
grouping i want to basically
have some selective data in this
and for that what i can do is
let's go for ship mode now this is
something what we have so
we are in this
data field
now we have this transform so let's go
back to transform again
and let's choose our orders
so that's the data we have
and now if you see here this is
you know huge amount of data
what we want is we want to group them
based on the shipping mode
so here you have a option called group
by so i can select this
i can go in here i can basically work on
okay get rid of duplicate values but
that's not what we want to do you want
to do a group by so as i said you can do
a group by from here or you can choose
from the transform option above and you
can do a group by so let's do a group by
now
how do you want to group the data so i'm
saying i want to group the data here
based on shipping mode
or
which is the other column you want to
use to do a group by so let's go for
shipping mode
and what is the new column name
right so we want to basically find out
that
you want to go for ship mode but
that's not enough i mean i can do a ship
mode and i can do a grouping by but you
want to just count the rows no that's
not what we want to do so let's go to
advanced so ship mode is fine so that's
your grouping right but then what we
also want to do is we want to do a
grouping based on
say sales
so here for example let's go for sales
okay
and what should we call this so might be
we can say
shipment
wise
sales whatever you would want to call
so you can basically
get
the operation do you want to really
count the rows no we want to basically
do a summing or we want to
might be find out an average price right
so let's do a sum
okay and
here
i would want to do a summing based on
say for example
sales
so this is what i'm going to use for
getting a count of the sales now
grouping by might be we will change this
instead of
[Music]
instead of sales we are using a ship
mode what we can also do is let's go for
a segment
and that would be valid grouping so it
will take a combination of ship mode
segmenting group the data based on that
and then get me the sales which is
which is basically let's call it
shipment wise sales
so it gets a sum so let's do a
okay
and
that's my more relevant data which i'm
looking at so i'm looking at the ship
mode i'm looking at what is the segment
and then i'm looking at what is the
total sales there i'm looking at
again the ship mode standard and home
office so always remember when you are
choosing multiple fields or multiple
columns for grouping by
you are basically having
a combination of two fields so that has
to be unique and your grouping is done
based on that so now you're looking at
the sales wise
and this is something as
an important information what we have
so we have done some transformation
and what you can do is
you can use
other ways like you can use pivot to get
individual values from it you can run on
merge queries which is
basically running some merge queries and
merge the query with another query in
this workbook if you have so you can go
for this now i can basically go for
apply and close
so just to add to the group by step what
we did was if you see here i have
removed the group by filter which we
just did a couple of minutes back and
what i have done is instead of
transforming your complete data set
you can basically create a copy of it so
for example i can just do a copy
and then i can come here and do a paste
and i have done that and i'm calling it
order summarized but this is my complete
data now what we will do here is we will
basically go ahead and do a grouping by
again like what we did earlier based on
your shipment
based on your segment
and
based on the sales so that's what we are
looking for so let's go for the ship
mode
and
we go for group by
and here you would want to go for
advanced to ship mode and this one i
will go for segment
so that's fine now we want the new
column name so let's say
shipment
wise
sales
so i want to do a summing not the
counting of rows and i want to do a
summation based on sales like what we
did earlier and then you say ok
and that basically
gives you the data here now
what we have is we have the resultant
data based on the data which is coming
in from here we did the same thing just
one minute back
but we worked on the original data set
so what i did was i created a copy and
now i'm working on this one
so i'll say close and apply
and now we are back to
our
desktop
so it is applying these changes where we
have done some transformations we have
done some grouping by
and what we can do is
once we have the data here we can
anytime look at our data sets or tables
so this is my original one
if you see now i have order summarized i
can just pull out this information
i basically have my
returns which we have not really touched
and we have the scientists so we have
all the four data sets here now what we
can also do is
let's look into order summarized and we
just have this data here so
this is fine and you can continue
working on this you can basically
merge columns from two different data
sets
and then you can get
the merged column
and you can rename it so you can
obviously do that
you can basically do a uncheck
whenever you're working on these data
sets so what you can do is
if you would want to work on
transforming for example let's go back
here
and say i want to do
some transformation on it so how did we
do it we just did a transform
and
you can go back to transform
so you have this data here and
the data what you have you might be
interested in transforming this into
something else
and then
you don't want to
maybe load this data so you have this
option where you are selecting orders
and then you have something called as
enable load which can be unchecked so
when you do a uncheck what will happen
is whatever changes you perform
only those changes related data set will
be loaded
and they will still be available but
this will not affect your
it will not affect your original one so
for example let's say copy
and let's go in here i will do a paste
let's say orders
oh i did a paste i need to
rename this
so let's renaming let's say orders
and here
i will say summarized
and i will say us
so i'm renaming it now let that get
loaded
we can perform some transformations on
it
so i
have here
there's my country so let's look for
country
yeah
and let's look for country so here i
will go for only united states
okay that's what i'm interested in
and then i can choose well i'm
interested in just central u.s
so i can basically go for
just the central u.s and i can get rid
of all of these
so now i should have only central u.s
data
and this is fine and this is the data
might be we are focusing on right now
for doing some visualization might be
looking at sales
might be looking at the product
names so you have the product name now
remember you don't see any filters here
right because the filters are
coming from the resultant set and your
transformation so
if you have any filters you would be
seeing in the top row now this is the
data we have
let's uh
let's not restrict it to region region
would then reduce my data but that's
good enough for us
i can just say no
i'm clearing off this filter
i'm still looking at united states but i
want to look at all the regions
yeah whatever we would be interested in
category
and that's anyways chosen as technology
which we had chosen when we were loading
the data
we have copiers in machines
right and
we can basically keep this now
this is fine i can apply the changes
i can apply the changes based on this
one
and what i can do is i can just say for
now apply
so that's going to apply all the changes
which you have done in orders or summary
or the new one right and what i can do
is now i can choose order and i can say
don't enable this in load
so it says disabling load will remove
the table from the report and any
visuals that use its columns will be
broken we are not creating any visuals
as of now the table will be removed so
that's fine
and now i will say close and apply
so what happens is you are loading the
data based on the changes
okay now you have your
order summarized you have returns you
have scientists but you basically do not
have orders anymore so that was not
loaded so i only have this one
i only have this one
and
you have returns you have scientists you
don't have the orders column right now
that particular data set was not loaded
at all because we did not
choose that to be loaded right now while
i'm in this
orders
which is
let's see here and actually you can drag
in yeah
so you have order summary and this has
basically kind of data which i'm looking
for so i really don't need the
orders table so you can do it in steps
and you can aggregate this you can have
aggregated data you can have all the
data which is filtered transformed
grouped by
and then basically just load it and the
original data set which you used that's
no more
being loaded here now at any point of
time if i really want
i can go back to transform data and
remember
it is still here it is still here it's
not gone right so you can basically
select this and you can say enable load
and you will have the data back which
you can continue working on right so
these are some quick transformations
which really help us
in
working on the datum now obviously if
you have data you want to perform some
left joins right joins
you have inner joins outer joins so you
can always do that you can take two
different data sets might be i'm
interested in taking the
orders summarized which talks about
standard class consumer shipment wise
sales
and here if i look at order summary i
have other details but the thing is we
need to make sure that these have the
values
these have the values say for example
the segment column here
and the segment column here can really
be used to join these two tables so if i
create a relationship or
if i create a join i can basically merge
the data so this is how you work on data
we will also see some more examples on
might be modeling the data using some
expressions to work on the data so we
already looked at creating a report
selecting particular fields
and then publishing the report onto your
power bi service now this is the report
which we had created which says state
order id sales and then i also added
this returned field and that was
basically by creating a relationship
between order and returns which we can
also have a look in model so this is the
relationship which is created if you
just place your cursor here it tells me
that we have a relationship between
order id of returns and order id of
orders and that basically allows me to
join the data bring it in my one report
now this is basically your data sources
you can look at and if you click on your
visualization so that shows you your
report now what we can also do is we can
make it interesting now we would not
want to
scroll through the fields to see
wherever or what was the
order or what was the order id which was
returned
now i can do a sorting i can filter out
what i can also do is i can use this
option which shows slicer here and that
basically allows me to work with this
data so we have this
report here and basically as i said you
can click in here it shows the data now
what i can do is i would want to filter
out information or slice the information
using your returned
either being yes or
having a field which has no value how do
we do that so basically i can drag and
drop the returned
here as a field which comes from returns
now that basically shows me only the
value as yes but i do know that there is
there are some fields which are blank
now how do i add filter to this so i can
click on this one
and
then i can click on slicer now once that
does so it basically pulls out all the
different values so you have either yes
or you have the blank field for returned
so what we can do is we can select yes
you will see only
the orders and their ids and sales where
the products were returned so that gives
me 108 000 118 and i can select blank so
that will basically get me all the
orders or products which were not
returned now this is a simple way when i
can add a filter to or a slicer to my
report to basically
give
viewers a choice of
selecting different fields and you can
add any number of slicers you can
basically say
i would want particular kind of
information so for example if i go into
orders and we know we have the state now
i do have the state information here and
basically i can
if i would be interested i could filter
this out in my report itself i can sort
it
i can look it in a different order what
i can also do is how about
bringing in state here and basically
dragging it here
so that gives me the state option it is
giving me a visual which is basically
giving me a geographic location of all
these points so yes that can be good
what i can also do is i can keep this
which basically shows me the state
map
might be it can be useful you can zoom
in you can zoom out you can look at
specific information here you can drag
and drop here so that's fine what i can
also do is i can
again take the state
and bring it here
and that basically can be instead of my
map i can go for slicer so that gives me
all the values here and which basically
allows users to choose the fields
or the states which you would be
interested in looking at so for example
if somebody is interested in looking at
the data for georgia just select this
one and you see the map automatically
shows you where in the map that's the
place
and it shows me all the sales for
georgia state now i can also basically
select yes and that shows me which were
the orders which were basically returned
so that gives me a quick overview of
statewise
what is the geographical location
if the orders were returned or maybe i
can just click on blank and it shows me
the non-returned orders
i can again go here and uncheck the
georgie option and that shows me all the
states now once you have done this this
looks like a comprehensive report which
can be useful for the viewers for your
management team and so on so we can just
do a save and that basically is saving
my report so i have this report now what
if i publish this report
so i can just do a publish
and when i publish it says okay
workspace so let's say select
and then it says replacing this
data set may impact two reports you
already have a data set named by this
one
view the impact i would say replace
or i will say
view impact so that basically takes me
to the power bi service because
sometimes we may have some reports which
we have already uploaded and
updating an existing report might
basically affect my existing report
so it basically shows me the impact
analysis it shows me one workspace there
are two reports they are they have not
been added to dashboard but these are
the ones which will get modified so
let's for example
as of now go ahead here
and let's look into my power bi so go
back to your desktop and i'll say no i
don't want to replace so click on cancel
so i do not want to publish it or it
might be what i can do is
i can try saving it as a different
report so let's say save as
and now i will basically say
additional
filters
okay let's save it
so now you see the name on the top
changes to additional filters and now
it's
saved to publish this
and now i can go ahead and publish it
select your workspace
and basically it says this is the report
being published with our additional
filters with a map which gives a
geographical
area showing us the information and then
basically what i can do is once it is
done i can
look into my power bi service like we
did earlier you can do a filtering
we can basically query this data we can
share it with other users who might be
interested in looking at this particular
data now this says it is done so it says
get quick insights and might be it's a
good option to
look into what kind of insights it's it
gives you so click on that
see the beauty of power bi where it
tries to search for
any kind of insights which it can gather
from the kind of report which you have
built
now once the insights are ready it will
let you know what we can also do is
we can come in here
click on
view data set
so you see now it shows your additional
filters
and here you have
option
where it should be showing your report
so let's say view
and view is fine
so
and if it doesn't show up
sometimes it might be taking time for
refreshing so you can always go here and
then you can click on your report
and that should get populated
so this is the report these are the
filters which i have
gives me an option of choosing all the
states
and basically allows me to edit the
report and
look at all the information here
meanwhile we can see here it is still
trying to gather some insights from the
data
and now you see there are some insights
here so it says sales which is coming up
and a subset of your data was analyzed
and the following insights were found so
you're looking at sales by
ship mode so it says standard class
second class first class and same day so
there were different shipping modes in
our data and that's what it shows me the
sales which one had the majority it
shows me the profit so which city or
state had more profit so new york city
has noticeable more profits here
average by shipping cost by sub
categories so there are these different
sub categories which we can look at such
as copiers and machines have noticeably
more shipping cost
profit by product name
and
you can basically look at the row id and
quantity so this is where you're looking
at a regression analysis
you're looking at row id and quantity so
there is a correlation between row id
and quantity so these are two different
variables or fields which are related
you're looking row id by category
row id so it says california has
noticeably more row ids
sales
your profit count of region and count of
returns
so there is a correlation again between
two different variables
average of shipping cost now we would
have taken lot of time building all
these visualizations
but power bi has already helped you in
gathering all these insights and then
you can basically select which one of
these is what you are interested in you
can focus and look for more information
based on all the fields it has given you
good amount of insights which will help
anyone who is looking at this particular
report
so that's your quick insights here
and we have this information
now
once you have this information this is
basically
where you have your focus mode so it
says subset of your data was analyzed
following insights were found you can
basically say download
and
here you have other options which allow
you to
work with your power bi so
let's look at this one so this is where
we have our report
and
we can continue exploring it more
one more interesting feature which power
bi has other than
having your insights ready to use
which is basically in your workspace and
you can basically use these insights
what we are looking at various options
here
and basically you have this option where
it says spin the visual if you are
interested in a particular
insight you can always spin it which you
can always go back and look into what
you can also do is you can
also click on edit report here now
that's a report which has already been
published
to
your power bi service not yet shared but
that can be shared or that can be
subscribed now once you click on edit
report
it has option of reading view mobile
layout you have basically an option
which says basically
options for navigating through the data
set
you can go for
how visuals on the canvas interact with
each other
you have all these options and one of
the good options is ask a question so
you can always click on ask a question
and that basically
says
some suggestions now you can open this
and it says okay ask a question about
your data try one of these to get
started what is the average sale
sort orders by order date sort orders by
product id
how many ship modes are there
compare quantity and discount so do not
worry that your report has
only four fields so it has state order
id sales and returned
with some filters but what about
you looking at how many ship modes are
there so it is already looking at your
data so if you click on this one here
and you can see what are the different
fields what we have and you have ship
date and ship mode so this is one of the
fields which it is showing you to ask a
question now what you can do is you can
say how many ship modes are there let's
click on that
let's ask this question it says four
ship modes and do you want to add this
to report yes you can you can let it be
as it is so you can basically keep this
question here
and here you have an option the visual
is showing number of ship modes
when you place your cursor here
if you see here turn this qna result
into a standard visual
and let's do that and basically it is
saying
number of ship modes
right so now that's the power of your bi
power bi which has basically allowed you
to ask a question and quickly
add a visual to your report now what we
can do
is we can basically save this
or you can say save as
and given a different name so might be
i'll just say save because i would want
to have this information and the report
is saved
so in this way you can basically not
only create smart visuals you can not
only relate
different data sources using data models
or relationships you can add maps you
can add filters you can add quick
questions
you can basically just go here and say
for example you would want to
ask a different question now we see the
fields here how about looking at the
shipping cost right so here i can say
um
what is the
[Music]
highest
shipping
cost and that shows me some suggestions
let's select that and that shows me the
value
which is great and i can keep it as it
is i can basically convert this to a
visual i may want to keep the question
because might be this question was asked
and
you would want to see the result here
might be you can move this somewhere
here
and that gives me some kind of question
which was asked and we can do a safe
and that's my report which has been
saved
in my bi service the data set is still
there you can basically go ahead and
share this
thank you for joining us today for any
questions please visit
www.simplylearn.com
or post any questions below on the video
thank you and have a great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you